so in this series of tutorials we'll see
how to build a reddit clone application
using spring boot and angular we will be
using spring boot spring mvc spring
security with jwt authentication spring
data jpa with mysql database to build
this application
so without wasting any time let's have a
look at the application we are going to
build
just a small note you can find the link
to the written tutorial of the series by
clicking on the link in the description
section where you can check out the
complete source code of this application
and there is also a written companion
for each part inside the tutorial so you
can go through it at your own pace
as i said before we are building a
reddit clone so reddit is of course a
very popular website that needs no
introduction
and this is how our homepage looks like
i have copied some of the css from
reddit to provide a similar look and
feel for our application
we have our header section with the
reddit icon on the left side and the
login and sign up buttons on the right
side we have our home page where you can
see different links which are posted by
the users
each post has a voting section where you
can either upload or download a post you
can also see there is a comment section
here which shows how many comments are
there for each post
you can click on read post button to see
the post and
comments for this post
if you want to create a post you need to
be logged in so first let me register
quickly by clicking on sign up button
and providing my details
and once you click on register button
you're navigated to the login page
you can also see a nice roaster
notification here on the top right side
so after the user registration we have
to activate the account before we log in
for that we receive an email to which
contains uh the activation link for the
account in this application i'm actually
using a fake smtp server called as
mailtrap instead of a real world mail
server so all the mails which we sent
from our application are sent to this
mail trap inbox
you can see that we have already
received an email with subject as please
activate your account and here as i am
using a free account we can only see the
text version of this email even though
we are sending an html template as the
email body
so let's copy this activation link
inside this email and open this in the
new tab and you can see that our account
is activated successfully
now we should be able to login let's go
back to our login page
type our credentials
and click on login
so now we are navigated to the home page
so first let's create a subreddit and
then create a post inside the subreddit
i will click on create subreddit button
give a title and description for the
subreddit and click on post
now let's create a post i will provide
the title
so you can see that we are navigated
back to the home page and this time you
can see the post we have just created it
shows the time as just now
now let's log in as a different user
and in the home page
i can upload or download this post we
have just created before so uh let's
upload this and you can see that the
upward icon now turns to green and even
if you reload the page it shows a visual
indication that the user has uploaded
this post the same thing applies also of
course for the download of the post and
the last thing is as you can see on the
top right section we have our username
if you click on that we see a menu and
let's click on profile
and in this page you can see all the
posts and comments which are created by
the user
so that is how our application looks
like and the next step would be to
actually start coding i will be first
developing the back end and then we will
see how to develop the front end so to
create the backend project the first
thing you have to do is to go to
start.spring.io website
this is the place where you will
generate our project with all the
required dependencies
for this project we will add spring web
as we are using spring mec
we will add a very useful library called
as lombok this library helps us to
generate the usual boilerplate code in
java like getters setters constructors
equals hash code methods etc
and the next thing is we also need
spring security spring data jpa
mysql java driver
and lastly we will also add java mail
sender dependency
once this is done you can click on
generate and
and the source code will be downloaded
to your machine
now let's unzip the project and open it
in your favorite ide
i will be using intellij for the rest of
the back-end development for this
project
and for the front-end i will be using
visual studio code so i open the project
in intellij now the first step would be
to create the domain entities for our
application
so let's expand this package structure
and go to the root package
and inside this package i already
created two packages called as model and
repository inside the model package we
have all the domain entities we need for
our application
the first one is the post entity it
contains a field post
it contains a free post id which is
annotated with id and generated value
with a strategy of identity
next we have a field name which has at
not blank annotation so when we validate
this entity before saving it to the
database if at all the name field is
either empty or null we will get a
validation error with the message as
post name cannot be empty or null
next we have the field url which can be
nullable
followed by the description field which
can also be nullable and is annotated
with a lob annotation because we can
have large chunk of text stored inside
this
description section we also have a vote
count for the post followed by a
reference to the user of the post
we have many to one relationship here
and a join
and lastly we are storing the time at
which the post is created through the
created date field and this field is of
type instant
and also we have a reference to the
subreddit entity with a many-to-one
relationship and a join one thing you
may have observed here is we don't have
the usual boilerplate code for this
entity like the getters setters and
constructors because these are generated
automatically at compile time using the
library called as lombok
the first annotation we are using here
is at data annotation this is
responsible to mainly generate the
getters and setters for our class it
also does some other things if you're
interested you can check the
documentation for this annotation
and the next we have a gpa annotation
entity followed by the all aux and works
constructor annotation which generates
the constructors for the class
and we also have a builder annotation
which will generate the builder methods
for our class
this annotation mainly uses the famous
builder design pattern to create the
objects for a class with data
you can check the link in the
description to know more about this
builder pattern
before we go any further to enable
lombok in your ide you have to install
lombok plugin
you can do that by pressing ctrl shift a
and typing plugins
and inside the plugin window search for
lombok and make sure you install this
plugin and restart the ide
after that
press ctrl shift a again
and type enable annotation processing
just make sure that this checkbox is
activated and click on ok
by doing this intellij will detect the
lombok annotation and generate the
related code at compile time
if you are using any other ide
i have added a link in the description
to the lombok website there you can find
step by step instructions on how to
enable lombok on your favorite ide the
next entity is subreddit we have the
usual fields here the id
name
description a reference to the list of
post with one to many relationship
the created date field
and reference to users with many to one
relationship
the user entity has the user id name
password
email
created date and enable fields
so here the user is enabled after
completing the email verification
process
which brings us to the verification
token entity
whenever a user is registered we
generate a token we store it in the
database through this entity and send
this token as part of the activation
link to the user whenever the user
clicks on that link we look up the user
associated with this token and enable
that user
we will discuss this functionality in
detail in the next upcoming videos and
next we have the vote entity which
stores the votes by the user
we distinguish whether a vote is either
upward or downward using a needham
called as vote type
the cnam has two possible values upward
and downward
and of course we have references to the
post and user entities and both of them
has many to one relationship
that leaves us with the last domain
entity comment
it has an id text a reference to the
post and the user with the many to one
relationships for both of them and a
join
and we have the time step at which the
comment is created through the a date
field of type instant so the next step
would be to create repositories to store
these entities inside the database
i have already created the repository
package and all the interfaces we need
so let's go through them one by one
first of all we have the post repository
which is extending the jpa repository
which is taking the post and the long as
generic arguments post is of course our
entity and long is the type of our
primary key
and this interface is annotated with at
repository annotation
next we have the subreddit repository
which is also extending the jpi
repositories and
taking subreddit and long as generic
arguments
followed by the user repository
and next we have a word repository
and lastly we have the comment
repository now let's configure the
database in our project for that open
the application.properties file inside
the source main resources package and
add the following properties the first
one is a property for mysql driver class
name we will use the driver class of the
com mysql cjdbc package the next
property is the data source url will
provide the jdbc url of our database
schema we will see how to create this
shortly using mysql workbench next up we
have our username and password of the
database
followed by the hibernate dialect
property
here as we are using mysql database
version 8 we are providing the mysql5
innodb dialect as the value for this
property
next up we have our ddl auto property
i'm going with the value as update for
now but if you are developing a
production grade application you will
give it a value of none and perform all
your database changes through migration
scripts using libraries like flyway or
liquibase just take a note of this point
and lastly we have the initialize and
show sql properties as true now before
we run our application we have to make
sure that the schema already exists in
your database here we have provided the
schema name as spring reddit clone now
let's open mysql workbench and once you
are connected to the local database in
the bottom left side corner of the
screen you can find the schema section
just right click over there and select
create schema
as i have already created the schema i
won't be creating it again
just make sure to add the schema name
here and click on finish to create the
schema and also make sure you put the
same schema name inside the spring
configuration pack inside the
application.properties file
now that should be it for the initial
setup
if you go back to intellij and go to the
main class
the spring reddit clone application
class just click on the green arrow to
the left side and click on debug
this should start up the spring context
and the tomcat server at port 8080
so inside the root package let's create
another package called less config
and inside this package let's create a
class called as security config
this class as the name suggests holds
the complete security configuration for
our back end the first thing we are
going to do is add the add enable web
security annotation to this class this
is the main annotation which enables the
web security module in our project which
we have added to this spring security
starter dependency
after that let's extend our class using
web security configure adapter this is
the base class for our security config
class
it provides us all the default security
configurations which we can override and
customize in our application
to do that first we have to override the
configure method which is coming in from
the base class
this configure method takes http
security object as input and inside this
method we will disable csrf protection
for our backend
we are disabling it because csrf attacks
can mainly occur when there are sessions
and when we are using cookies to
authenticate the session information
as rest apis are stateless by definition
and as we are using json web tokens for
authorization we can safely disable this
feature
next up we will allow all the incoming
requests to our backend api whose
endpoint url starts with slash api slash
auth
and we make sure that any other request
which does not match this pattern should
be authenticated
so we are done with the security
configuration for now let's create the
endpoint to register our users
i'm going to create a package called as
controller
and inside this package i'm going to
create a class called as auth controller
and i'm going to add rest controller
annotation on top of this class
followed by the request mapping
annotation which takes the value slash
api slash auth
now let's create a post mapping inside
the class with value as slash signup
let's also create a method called as
sign up
and to this method we will be giving an
input of type register request
through this class we'll be transferring
the user details like username password
and email as part of the request body
we call this kinds of class as a gto
that means a data transfer object
i am going to create this class and put
it inside a package called as dto
and to this class let's add our lombok
annotations at data at all logs
constructor and lastly nox constructor
now let's declare the fields the first
one would be username
followed by email and lastly the
password field
now let's create a class called as auth
service inside a new package
called as service
this all service class contains the main
business logic to register the users
that means creating the user object and
saving it to the database
and sending out activation emails etc
i will create a method called as sign up
inside the class which takes in the
register request object as input and the
first thing we have to do is to create
an object for the user class
and we will map the data we have from
the register request object to the user
object
first one would be the username
email
and password fields
the created field i will pass in the
value as instant dot now this is the
java 8 class to get current time and
lastly by default we will disable the
user so let's set the value for ease
enabled as false and once the user is
successfully
validated we will set this value we will
set the enable flag as true
before saving the user object to the
database we have to make sure that we
encode the password storing the password
in clear text is a very bad idea so
imagine that if your database is
compromised you have to make sure that
it would be very hard for the hacker to
actually crack the password
that's why we encoded using different
hashing algorithms which makes it very
hard to decode the passwords one of the
best hashing algorithms we can use in
this scenario is the bcrypt hashing
algorithm spring security provides us a
class which implements this algorithm
called as bcrypt password encoder now
let's use this class to encode our
passwords
i will go back to security config class
and here i will create a bean for the
password encoder
as the password encoder is an interface
we have to create a bin manually inside
the configuration class and whenever we
are auto wiring this bean we will get an
instance of type bcrypt password encoder
now let's go back to our service and
autobuy the password encoder
now let's call the encode method of the
password encoder before setting the
password field for the user
and that should be it spring will now
take care of encoding the password now
it's time to save our user inside the
database for that let's first automate
the user repository in our class
and inside the signup method let's type
user repository.save
and pass the user object to the save
method
now it's time to do some refactoring for
this class you can see that we are using
auto wired annotation there is no there
is actually nothing wrong with using
auto wired annotation but it is not
usually recommended to use it because we
are using field injection here and
spring recommends us to use constructor
injection whenever possible so i will
add a link to a very good article which
explains why to use constructor
injection over field injection but just
make sure to check that link
i will not explain it in detail in this
video but
so let's remove this ultraviolet
annotation and declared our field as
final
and usually we have to create a
constructor and set the variable for our
fields
and set the variable for our fields but
all this is taken care by the h haulocks
constructor let's add that to our class
and lastly let's not forget to add the
transactional annotation to this method
as we are interacting with the
relational database
now let's enhance our registration
process by sending out account
activation emails
for this the idea is to generate a
verification token right after we save
the user to the database and send that
token as part of the verification email
once the user is verified then we enable
the user to log into our application by
setting the enable field as true
let's create a method called as generate
verification token
which takes user object as input
and let's generate a random token here
we can do that by typing uuid
dot random uuid
this will generate a unique and random
128 bit value which we can use as our
verification token
now it's just enough to send now it's
just not enough to send this token
through email and forget about it we
also need to purchase this token in our
database so if the user chose to verify
the account after two or three days we
may not have this in memory at the time
so it's better to save this token in the
database and whenever the user has
verified the email here we will look up
the token and then enable the user
so i will create an object for
verification token and pass in the user
and token details
now let's auto wire the verification
token repository and save the token to
the database
and also we will just return this token
back to our signup method
right now it's time to send out the
activation email for the users
as first step we need to add some
additional dependencies to our project
if you want to send html emails from our
application we will use a template
engine called as time leaf which enables
us to create html templates and use
those templates to send the emails let's
go to our pom.xml file and let me add
the timely starter dependency
now let's go to the source main
resources folder and inside the template
folder here we create a html file called
as mailtemplate.html
and inside this file i will paste this
html code which contains a span tag and
here a variable called message is
injected through timeleaf's text tag
back inside the service package let's
create a class called as mail content
builder
this class contains a method called as
build
and this method takes the email message
we want to send to the user as input
and we set this email message inside the
time leaves context object
we are doing that by using the set
variable method of context
and lastly we will be passing the html
file name and the context to the
template engine through the template
engines process method
so at runtime timeline will
automatically add the email message to
our html template
okay now it's time to send out email
messages let's create another class
inside the service package called as
mail service
let's add an annotation to this class
the usual service and at all logs
constructor annotation
let's create a method called as send
mail and this method takes the object of
type notification email as input if you
go inside the notification email class
you can see that it encapsulates all the
details we need for an email such as
recipient subject and body of the email
let's go back to send email method and i
will quickly paste in some code here
and now let me explain this
so we are constructing an instance of
type my message helper inside the lambda
which creates an instance of type my
message prepared my message preparator
and to this my message helper we are
passing in the data like the sender
information we are hard coding it as
springreddit.email.com
this can be any fake email address you
like
but here as we are using a fake smtp
server it doesn't matter if you want to
use a real world smtp server like gmail
or something else then you have to give
a real email address here or else it
won't work
so moving on we have our set to set
subject and set text methods we are just
mapping these fields from notification
email object
but for the set text method we are
calling the build method of mail content
builder object
so this method will return the message
in the html format
lastly we are using the send method of
the java mail sender class and we are
logging a message called as activation
email sent but we have a compilation
error here because we did not define
this log variable anywhere for that we
can use the slf 4j annotation from
lombok which will create an instance of
slf4j logger object and inject it into
our class
so we have this particular code wrapped
inside the try catch block and inside
the catch block we are throwing a new
exception called as spring reddit
exception with a message
let's create this class and place it in
another package called as exceptions
this clash should extend the runtime
exception class and inside the
constructor we will call the super
method
and pass in the exception message
so you may ask why are we doing this
what is the purpose of doing this right
so let's discuss about this briefly
in our back end especially when we are
building rest apis exceptions are pretty
common in our code so whenever those
exceptions occur we don't want to expose
the technical information to the user
for instance like illegal state
exception null pointer exception or
socket exception something like this we
should ideally present this information
in an understandable format we can do
that by creating custom exception like
this spring reddit exception and pass in
our own exception messages
you can either create multiple
exceptions for each use case in our
application or create one exception to
your whole application and reuse them
everywhere in your code
alright so we have covered all the logic
to send out the emails but one thing we
still need to do is to configure the
smtp server details in our application
for that we are going to use a fake smtp
server called as mailtrap you can use
this service to test your code which
sends out the emails first of all you
can go to mailtrap.io and make sure to
sign up for the service and after
signing up you can get
and after signing up you get your smtp
server details inside the inbox these
details look something like how you see
on the screen you get a host of the mail
server a port which we can use and a
username and password so let's configure
these details inside our
application.properties
so i am going to copy these properties
here we have a spring mail host port
username and password
all these details you can get through
the mailtrap service and lastly the
protocol we're going to send emails
would be smtp okay now we have
configured our smtp server and created
our mail service we still need to call
our mail service from our sign up method
let's do this
back inside the odd service class let's
inject the mail service class and write
after this
and right after the generate
verification token method i am going to
type mail service dot send
and we are going to create an object of
type notification email
and to this
email the and to this object the first
argument would be the subject let's pass
in a string please activate your account
as the first argument the second
argument would be the recipient for that
we type user.getemail and the last one
is the body of the email i'm going to
paste in a string here this string
contains a url which redirects the user
to our server and to this we are going
to append a verification token so
whenever the user clicks on this url we
take the token from the url parameter
and look it up in our db
fetch the user who created this token
and enable that user that's how the flow
would be
so the remaining part here is we have to
call this signup method from our auth
controller let's do that back inside the
controller i am going to inject the odd
service class and call the signup method
and so if the registration is successful
we have to send a message to the client
we can do that by just returning a
response entity which takes a string as
the first argument and will pass the
string user registration successful
and the second argument would be an enum
value okay from http status enum
okay we are ready to test okay now we
are ready to test our registration flow
let's start the server and go to postman
so i am using a rest client called
postman to make calls to our backend
here
i'm making a post call to our sign up
endpoint with the user details in the
body now let's click on send
and we go to response brock and we got a
response back from the server as user
registration success
the first thing is let's check the
database and check if our user is really
saved and the password is encoded or not
so inside the mysql workbench you can
see that we have our user test user 5
and the password we have typed as
password 5 in the initial request but
you can see that the password is encoded
inside the database
now let's check if we got the email or
not let's open our mail trap inbox as
you can see we already got the email and
you can see the activation link in the
email
if you copy this activation link and
open it in the new tab
nothing happens because we did not
create the endpoint to activate the user
let's do that now
now inside the auth controller let's
create an endpoint which contains get
mapping with value as account
verification followed by token which
acts as a path variable now let's create
a method which returns a response entity
of type string
with name as verify account
and as we are passing the token as the
parameter inside the url
we have to add path variable annotation
to grab the token
and now inside the method let's call
auth service
and this time we call the method verify
account and pass in the token to this
method
of course this method does not exist yet
so let's also create it
so here we have to query the
verification token repository by token
which we receive as input to the method
so here let's type verification token
repository dot find by token
and pass the token as input
of course this method definition does
not exist in our repository so let's
create it and this find by token method
should return an optional of
verification token entity so back inside
the verify account method let's store
this written type into a variable and as
we are returning an optional here in
case if the entity does not exist we can
call the oral throw method and throw the
custom exception with message as invalid
token
all right now we have to query the
corresponding user who is associated
with this token and enable that user for
that let's create a method with name
fetch user and enable which takes
verification token as input and inside
this method let's get the username by
typing
verificationtoken.getuser.getusername
and store this written type inside a
string variable called username
now let's type userrepository.find by
username and pass in the username as
input
let's also create this method inside the
user repository and this returns an
optional of type user now let's also
call the oral store method and to this
method let's pass in the supplier which
throws our custom spring reddit
exception with message as usual not
found with name
and we will append the username to the
end
so now let's store this result inside
the variable user and let's enable this
user by typing user dot set enabled as
true
lastly save the user inside the database
and mark the method as transactional
now let's go back to our auth controller
and let's return a response entity back
to the client by typing written new
response entity let's pass in the first
argument as message account activated
successfully and the second argument
would be http status dot ok
ok now it's time to test the user
verification let's start the server
register with the new user and test the
verification process
okay so you can see that we received the
response accounts activated successfully
as expected now if you observe carefully
an interesting thing is our api call to
register users took more than 10 seconds
to complete that means the user has to
wait for 10 seconds after he clicked on
the sign up button in the ui
this is because we are sending a
verification email after storing the
user inside the database this kind of
operations are very expensive and takes
time to complete so as we are contacting
an external mail server so of course
there will be delay and this response
will be slow what we should do in this
case is to execute the code which sends
the verification email asynchronously by
running this part in a different thread
if you're not aware of what is
asynchronous processing i suggest you to
google about it i will also provide a
link in the description to know more
about this
but so fortunately in spring um running
this piece of code asynchronously is not
complicated
spring framework provides us with
asynchronous capabilities which we can
use whenever we required to enable that
we have to go to our application class
and on top of the class just type at
enable async
this should already enable the
synchronous processing through and now
let's go to the piece of code which is
responsible to send the email
that would be the send email method
inside the mail service class and on top
of this method type at async
so that is it now our code should run
asynchronously and the response time for
register users api call should be much
faster
so let's restart our server and test it
again
so as you can see the api call is taking
very less time and looks far better than
the previous response time this is the
advantage with asynchronous processing
anytime taking any time taking task can
be executed asynchronously
so
these long running responses won't
affect the user experience an
alternative way to do this is to use
message queues like active mq or
rabbitmq
but this these are too heavyweight for
our use case right we don't have um
we don't need to provide reliability to
the emails but you want to put it we
want to keep it simple so but if you are
using this email sending functionality
on a larger scale
uh using this rabbit mq our active mq
would be
recommended
so let's have a look at our
authentication flow how would look like
on the high level before we go and
implement it
so first of all we have a client who
wants to login to our server
the client makes a login request to the
server by providing the credentials the
server receives this information and
validates the credentials
and if they are matching it creates a
json web token and sends this
information back to the client
the client uses this token to
authenticate itself for all the
consecutive requests it's going to make
to the server
so once the server receives a request
with this token it first validates this
token whether it's the same token which
is generated by the server or not and
after the successful validation it
responds to the client with the required
data
before we dive in and start coding i
would like to take a moment and explain
you how the authentication mechanism
works in spring security this is a high
level uh overview because there are also
lots of hidden uh functionalities and
hidden components
used in this uh in this uh in this
authentication mechanism
and because we are implementing in
spring using spring security is not so
straightforward if you are not clear
what you are doing its very easy to get
lost and confused
okay here is the diagram which shows us
the high level flow which is followed
inside our project
these are the main components we will be
using to create our authentication
mechanism the first thing is of course
our auth service which we will receive
which will receive the authentication
request and inside this odd service we
grab the username and password from the
request and create a username password
authentication token class
we will pass this class to an
authentication manager which takes care
of all the authentication of its which
takes of authenticating our users this
authentication manager will use an
interface called as user detailed
service which can fetch the user details
from multiple sources
in our use case it would be database
if the user details are incorrect we get
an exception at this stage and if they
are correct the user details are passed
on to authentication manager which
returns an authentication object back to
the odd service
so at this moment our authentication is
successful
so as you see in the previous diagram we
will create a jwt
and send it back to the user as a
response
so this is a bit in-depth explanation of
the authentication flow i hope it is
clear for you
without any further delay let's start
coding
all right so the first thing we need to
do is to update our security config
class we have to create our
authentication manager for that spring
uses a class called last authentication
manager builder
so let's configure this
for that let's create a method public
void configure global
and now let's inject the authentication
manager builder to this method using
method injection we can do that by
adding authentication manager builder
object as input and adding ultrawide
annotation on top of this method
inside this method now we can use the
authentication manager builder and since
for this object we have a method user
details service
this method takes input of type user
details service though we have saw so we
saw what this user detail service does
in the previous in the previous diagram
so it mainly loads the user data from
different sources in our case it would
be database and provides the user data
to spring so as this is an interface we
have to create an implementation class
so let's create a class called as user
details service impul
which implements the user details
service interface
now inside this class let's override the
load user by username method this method
takes the username as input and returns
the user details object let me quickly
paste the logic we are going to use in
this method
so first of all we are acquiring the
user repository to retrieve the user
based on the username
if the user does not exist we throw a
username not found exception this is the
exception which is provided by spring
and with that user object we create
another object which is like a wrapper
with the same name user this clair this
class is provided by spring framework
which implements the user details
interface
and here we are just mapping the user
details to this user class
and lastly we are providing an authority
called as simple granted authority for a
role called user
so now we have the core part of the user
authentication let's create the logic
where we receive the request from the
client
so for that let's open the auth
controller class and here let's create a
new endpoint with a post mapping with
value as
slash login
let's create a method by the name of
login and to this method we'll pass an
object of type login request
so this is the same dto
this is a similar dto we used for
register for a registration
functionality called as register request
and let's create this login request
class and this class contains mainly two
fields
a username and a password
and let's also add the necessary lombok
annotations
uh namely data
all aux constructor and nox constructor
now let's go back to earth controller
and type odd service dot login and pass
the login request object as input to
this method
let's create this method inside all
service
now what we need to do here is to
implement the logic to authenticate the
user
as we saw in the diagram minutes ago the
auth service contains the logic to
create username password authentication
token and use authentication manager to
perform login
to do that first we have to autowire
authentication manager
into the odd service class
if you read the documentation for
authentication manager we can observe
that this is an interface
and for an interface if we do not
mention explicitly what kind of bin to
create spring throws an exception
because there are multiple
implementations of authentication
manager
so we have to create a bean inside our
security config which extends the web
security configure adapter so let's do
that
so whenever we auto wire authentication
manager spring finds this bean and
injects it into our class
now let us continue the implementation
inside the earth service class let's
type authentication manager dot
authentication
and here we are going to pass an object
of type username password authentication
token by typing new username password
authentication token
and passing the username and password
from the login request object as the
constructor arguments
okay so let's go back to our diagram and
see where we are
we implemented the part where we create
the username password authentication
token
we pass this token to authentication
manager's authenticate method
which in turn calls the user detail
service
we also implemented the logic to read
the user from database and return the
user details to the authentication
manager
so now this authentication manager
verifies our credentials in the
background and if they are matching it
returns us an object called as
authentication
that means we have implemented the
authentication functionality but not
completely we still have to create json
web tokens and send it as a response to
the client
so before we create the functionality to
create json web tokens we have to add
some even dependencies
so open up the bom.xml file and make
sure you add these three jwt
dependencies
the jjwt api jwt impel and jjwt jackson
so now let's create a class with the
name jwt provider
i will create this class in a separate
package called as security
let's add the service annotations to
this class and
now let's create a method public string
generate token
and this method takes an object of type
authentication as input
and inside the method i will type
dot get principle
let's cast it to user object and store
it in a variable called as principle
now we have the user information we can
create our jwt by using the following
code
so here we are using the jwts class to
construct our jwt
we set the user name as the subject for
the json rib token and to sign the json
web token we should provide a key which
we will implement shortly once we
provide the subject and sign the jwt
we get the token retained in the form of
a string
and now coming to the key
in this example we'll be using
asymmetric encryption that means we'll
be using a keystore to sign the json web
token
specifically the private key of the key
store to sign our json with token
i'll quickly copy the required code and
we'll explain you how we can use private
private key to sign the json with tokens
all right now let's go through the code
first we have a field called as keystore
and we are initializing this field
inside this post construct block
which is goes inside a method named init
we are providing a keystore instance of
type jks to the field and in the next
line we are getting the input stream
from the keystore file with the name
springblog.jks
this is the keystore file i also used
for my other tutorial series build a
blog with spring boot and angular
if you're interested you can also check
out the series inside the description
section
so once we load the input stream from
the keystore you have to provide the
input stream to the load method of the
keystore followed by the password of the
keystore
and after that we just have to read the
private key from the key store and pass
it to the jwts class to sign our json
web token
to read the private key should mainly
provide the alias of the keystore
followed by the password of the keystore
and this particular code throws so many
different exceptions so as a best
factories we are wrapping all those
exceptions and just throwing a custom
runtime exception with an understandable
and meaningful exception message
now let's call the generate token method
of our jwt provider class from inside
the odd service
before that we have to store the
authentication object inside the
security context
we can do that by typing security
context holder
dot get context
dot set authentication
and to this method to enter this method
called pass in the authenticate object
so if you want to check if a user is
logged in or not we can just look up the
security context for the authenticate
object for the authentication object and
if we find the object then we can be
sure that the user is logged in and if
not the user is not logged in
so now let's inject the jwt provider
class inside the odd service
and back inside the method we will call
the generate token method of the jwt
provider and of course this method
returns a string which is our
authentication token
now we can send this back now we can
send this token back to the user
to send this token we will use a dto
called as authentication response
let's create this class inside the dto
package
this class contains the fields with name
authentication token and username
both are of type string
so now inside the login method let's
create an object for authentication
response
fill that object with our token and the
username
and then return it back to the
controller
and inside the controller let's add a
written statement
to our call to the login method of the
auth service
and change the written type of the
method to authentication response so now
it's time to test whether the login is
working or not
but before that make sure that you have
this springblog.jks file inside the
resources folder or else the jwt
creation won't work
so now let's start the server and make a
login request using postman
so i made the login request using the
account i have created before and you
can see that we received the token the
authentication token and username as
response back from the server
in the last video we saw a sequence
diagram which provides a high level
overview of the authentication mechanism
in this video we're going to dive deep
onto the fifth point
where we validate the json web token on
the server so this is how the actual
process looks like the client makes a
request to the server
the request is intercepted by a custom
filter called as jwt authentication
filter
this filter will retrieve the access
token and validates it if the validation
is successful the request will be
forwarded to the corresponding
controller
now let's go ahead and implement this
functionality so first of all we are
going to create a class called as jwt
authentication filter inside the
security package
and this class extends the once per
request filter class
and
we're going to overwrite some methods
and inside the do filter internal method
we will intercept the request and fetch
the token from the request headers
because the client sends the token to
the server as part of the request
headers by following the bearer scheme
so inside the two filter internal method
i will call a method called as get jwt
from request and this method takes in
the http servlet request as input
so to get the token from this request
object we have to get the authorization
header from the request
we can do that by typing
request.getheader of authorization
let's store this value inside a string
called as bearer token
and this token is now sent
in the structure you see on the screen
so it starts with the term bearer
followed by a space and followed by the
json group token
to get the token we have to exclude the
term bearer and just retrieve the term
and just retrieve the token
we can do that by using substring method
of string class
so here i am going to type
bearertoken.substring of 7.
so let us store the token inside a
variable called as jwt and now let's go
to the jwt provider class and create a
method called as validate token
this method takes in the jwt and as the
name suggests it is responsible to
validate the json web token
if you remember in the last video we
used asymmetric encryption to create our
tokens by assigning them with the
private key from our key store and now
we will validate the token by using the
public key
we can do that by typing jwts
dot parser
dot set signing key
and here we're going to pass in the
public key
for that let's create a method called as
get public key
and here i will quickly copy paste the
implementation which is very similar to
the get private key method
implementation but here we are going to
call the getcertificate method of the
keystore so we will get the certificate
which goes by the alias name of the
keystore
and then we call the method get public
key which returns the actual public key
from the keystore
and of course as this piece of code
throws some checked exceptions willing
to catch them and read through them as a
runtime exception
and now back inside the validate token
method
i will call the parse claims jws method
and pass in the json web token which we
are receiving as input
and if this particular piece of code is
executed without any errors we can be
sure that the json web token is
validated so in the next step we are
just going to return the boolean value
true
so now let's inject the jwt provider
class inside the jwt authentication
filter class and call the validate token
method
so now if we have a valid token we have
to load the user from the database and
set the user details in the spring
securities security context
to do that first we have to get the
username from the token we can easily
retrieve the username from the token
because we are using it as a subject
when creating the token
i will go back to the jwt provider class
and create a method called as get
username from jwt which takes the token
as input
inside the method i'm going to get the
body of the token which is nothing but
the claims
and from the claims object i can
retrieve the subject by typing claims
dot get subject
so this is going to be a string
let's return this value from the method
and also let's change the written type
of this method to string
back inside the jwt authentication
filter class
let's call the get username from jwt
method
and now we have the username
again i'm going to copy the code which
retrieves the user from the database and
sets the user details into the security
context
first we are constructing here
so here first we are constructing an
instance of type username password
authentication token and then storing
this inside the spring security context
so now the last part is to call the
filter chain if our token is valid
spring is going to find the user details
inside the security context and it will
fulfill our request if not it will throw
an exception which we will see at the
end of the video okay so we implemented
the validation part now to test this we
don't have any secured apis so let's go
ahead and create one api to create and
read subreddits
let's create a class called as subreddit
controller and the first thing we have
to do when we create a controller is to
annotate the class as rest controller
and for this api we're going to provide
the request mapping as slash api
subreddit
let's also add the usual lombok
annotations we are going to need
and the first method we are going to
implement is the create subreddit method
this method will follow a post mapping
and as the request body we will send the
information in the form of a dto
let's call this dto as a subreddit dto
and let's also create this class
so basically to create a subreddit the
information we are going to need is just
subreddit name and description but we
are also going to read the subreddit
information for that we need the id of
the subreddit and lastly the number of
posts which are inside the subreddit
let's create all these fields inside the
dto and provide all the required lombok
annotations
okay so we should always try to avoid to
write business logic in our controllers
the responsibility is to receive
requests from the client and delegate
them to the service layer
so to implement the functionality we are
going to need a service class let's
create this class inside the service
package with the name as subreddit
service and inside this class let's
create a method called as save
which is responsible to create and save
the subreddit information
to create the subreddit first we have to
map the information we need from dto to
subreddit entity let's create a method
to do this mappings which is called as
map subreddit to dto
inside this method we're going to use
the builder pattern to construct our
subreddit entity
and we'll just return it back to our
method we can also use some mapping
libraries like mapstract to make our
life easier
i will introduce that library in the
upcoming videos but for now let's
concentrate on creating the api and test
the token validation logic
so we have our subreddit entity let's
save this inside the repository for that
we need to first inject the subreddit
repository into a class and later just
save the entity by typing subreddit
repository.save
after saving the entity we can set the
id field inside our dto and return it
back to the controller
back inside the controller let's inject
the subreddit service and call the save
method
let's store the written type and return
it back to the client but we just won't
return the subreddit detail we will wrap
the dto using spring's response identity
class in this way spring provides us
some sensible default information as
response to the client
we will type response entity dot status
as it is a post call and as we are
creating a subreddit the appropriate
written type for this kind of rest call
is value 201
in spring this value is represented by
the enum created
and lastly let's include the subreddit
dto as the body of the response entity
and written it back to the client
now let's also quickly create an api to
read the subreddits
for that i will create a get all
subreddit method
which supports get mapping now let's
create a method called as get all inside
the subnet service
and the most important annotation we
forgot to add before
is the at transactional annotation
as we are using a relational database to
guarantee consistency we need to add the
annotations to all the methods which are
going to interact with the database
for the get all method we will add the
transactional annotation with read-only
flag as true
so inside this method let's simply call
the find all method of the subreddit
repository and now we should do the
mappings from subreddit entity to the
subreddit dto
let's create another method to perform
these mappings
and here let me quickly copy the
necessary code as we are not doing
anything complex apart from just some
simple mappings
once this is completed return the dto
back to the controller and the
controller will return this tool
and the controller will return this dto
with appropriate http status
all right so we are coming to the end of
the video
before we go ahead and test our
validation logic and apis we have to
make sure that spring security knows
about our jwt authentication filter
class so let's go to the spring security
config class and inside the configure
method let's add this line of code
which is http security dot add before
and to this method we are passing the
jwt authentication filter
followed by the username password filter
so now spring tries to first check for
the access token the jwt token
before trying the username password
authentication scheme
with that all the configuration part is
completed so let's go ahead start our
server and test our implementation
so after starting the server open your
favorite res client i'm using postman
and here i've already prepared some
requests to show you how it is working
first of all i have made a login request
with some credentials and i received a
token as response
so we are going to use this token inside
the bearer scheme
and make a request to create the
subreddit
as you can see the request was
successfully completed
and we received back the id of this
update
now let's try to read all the subreddits
also for this i have prepared a request
and here you can see all the subreddits
i have in my database
lastly let's test the negative case that
means what happens if we try to send an
invalid token to the server
so let's go to the authorization tab and
remove the last character from the token
and send the request
so as you can see we got back an error
message from our server
if we put back the correct access token
and make the request again
you should see all this updated
information
so let's have a look at what is
mapstruct if you go to the mapstruck.org
website you can see in the home page it
is written that is a java library which
generates the mapping code uh the
mapping logic in our application that
means if you have two two objects and
you want to map the data between these
two objects we can use mapstruct to
generate the mapping code by just using
some annotations
if you scroll down you can see the
section map struct in two minutes here
we have an example where we have a car
object and a car dto object so if you
want to map the data between these two
objects first usually what you will do
is create a new car object and then use
the setter methods to set the data for
each field
and imagine if you have like five or ten
fields or more than ten fields in the
pujo class then you have to write the
mapping code manually so this will be
pretty uh sometimes may be complex and
also mainly it's pretty boring to write
this kind of code so we can just
ask abstract to generate this kind of
code automatically by just writing the
method definition which takes in the
source object as input and we provide
the target object type as the written
type of the method and that's all we
have to do mapstruck will then generate
all the required mappings at compile
time
and so we will actually see how it
generates the code and what kind of code
it generates very soon but i hope you
understand what is abstract so let's go
ahead and install this library in our
project okay so let's go to the
documentation section in the home page
and under the apache maven section you
can see the the library details in the
form.xml file so let's just copy these
details into the corresponding section
of our pom.xml file we need to copy the
dependency and the plugin
so the only change we have to do here is
to add also the long block dependency to
the annotation processor parts because
lombok is also a library which generates
code at compile time in our project so
if you forgot to add this lombok
dependency you will get some compilation
errors in your project so so that's it
for the installation we are ready now to
use the mapping map struct in our
project so let's start by creating some
mappings in our subreddit service first
of all i'm going to create a new package
called smapper and inside this package
i'll create a new interface with the
name subreddit mapper
and now let's animate this interface
with headmapper and pass in the
component model value as spring
the first method we are going to define
is the map to dpto method
so this method takes in the subreddit
object as input and returns us back the
subreddit dto object
so if we compare the fields we have id
name description posts created date and
user fields inside the subreddit and
inside subreddit we have id name
description and post count
so we have some fields which with the
similar field names and also types
so maps track will identify and generate
the mapping logic automatically for
these fields
and for the remaining field the number
of posts
this is just an integer field we have to
create mapping from list of post to
integer that means we have to just
return the size of this list we can do
that by creating a new method called as
map post
so which takes in a list of posts as
input
and inside this method we will just
return number of post dot size so that
means we're just returning the size of
this list so we can tell to maps to use
this method when mapping the post field
by just annotating by using annotation
called as app mapping with target as
number of posts
and here we are using a method to do
this to use the mapping
and here we're using a method to do the
mapping so we will just use that method
in the form in the field called
expression so we just type expression
and we pass in the java so let's try to
compile this interface if you're using
intellij you can type ctrl shift f9
and now you can check the implementation
to see the generated code by mapstract
let's create mappings from subreddit dto
to subreddit entity
we can do that by declaring another
method but in this case we just add an
annotation called as inherit inverse
configuration so this and annotation
will create the mappings similar to map
subreddit to dto method but instead this
time it will create mappings from
subreddit gto to subreddit entity
and in this case actually we can ignore
the post field because we have to set
this field when creating the post
now let's also compile this code and
check whether the mappings are created
or not
so as you can see we have generated the
mapping successfully also for this
method now it's time to refactor the
existing code by first removing the
mapping methods and replacing them with
the methods from subreddit mapper
so in the previous video i forgot to add
an endpoint to retrieve a subreddit
based on the id
so let's quickly add this
endpoint
inside the subreddit controller i have
created a method called as getsubreddit
which takes an id of type long
and this is also a path variable
and i've also added the get mapping
annotations which takes the id as the
value
inside this method i'm calling the get
subject method of the subreddit service
and this subreddit so and this get
subreddit method is
actually retrieving the subreddit based
on the id
and then doing the mapping and then
returning the value
and then returning the subreddit back to
the controller
all right now let's start our
application and let's try to create a
subreddit and see if the mapping is
working correctly or not
okay so now let's go back to intellij
and let's start creating the api to
create and read post
the first thing we have to do is to
create a class called as post controller
and let's annotate this class with the
usual annotations rest controller
request mapping with value slash api
slash posts
and the last one is all aux constructor
annotation
so i will just copy paste all the
methods which we are going to create
here so the first one is a post mapping
which is of course used to create new
posts for this methods we are taking a
post request as input and let's create
this class inside the dto package
and this class contains the fields post
id subreddit name
post name url and description
and the remaining methods in our
controller are get mappings we have one
method to read all the posts in our
application
one method to written a particular post
and another method to return all the
posts under a subreddit
and the last method is to return posts
which are created by a specific user
okay so let's implement these methods
inside our post service class of course
it's not existing let's create this
class first inside the service package
and let's add the service and all logs
constructor annotations to this class
now let's create the method save which
takes the post request object as input
now here we have to create the mappings
from post request to post entity
i have
so i have already created a post mapper
interface for this
so let's go into that interface and you
can see the first annotation we have is
a mapper annotation from abstract on top
of our interface and the first mapping
method you see is to create a post from
the post request object
so to create a post we not only need the
post details but also the subreddit and
the user details we'll be passing these
details through the post service
class to this method and you can see
here that we have mappings for the
fields created date subreddit user and
description
and the first mapping for the field
created date here i'm using the
expression property and passing the
value as instant dot now so this value
will be mapped to the created date field
inside the post object
next one is the for the fields user and
subreddit
so here the field names are same between
for these two objects that means post
request and post so we can go ahead and
remove these mappings because of the
field name matches in the source and
target objects then we don't need to
explicitly mention the mappings that
will be taken care by mapstruct the last
mapping is for the field description
here we have to mention that the source
is inside the post request object that's
why we put the value as post request dot
description
in the same way we have the other
mappings for the method called as
map2d2o
and here we are mapping from
and here we are mapping from post object
to the post response up so the first
mapping is for the field id inside the
post response and here the source is the
post id and followed by the post name
description and url
and the next mappings are for the fields
subreddit name inside the post response
but this for this field we are get using
the subreddit the name field inside the
subreddit inside the post class that
means if i go into post we have the
field subreddit and if i go inside
subreddit we have a name field so we
want to map this particular field to the
post response
subreddit
name field so that's what we are
inferring here through this post through
this annotation we will be mapping the
subreddit dot name field to the
subreddit name field inside the post
response the same applies also for the
username field
so as i said before we can remove the
mappings whenever where the source and
the target names are the same so let's
do that
now let's compile this interface and see
whether the mappings are generated or
not
i will type control shift f9 which is
the shortcut to compile in intellij
and if you click on the green button
here you can see the implementations
which are generated by mapstruct
let us go back to the post service class
inside the save method let's implement
the necessary logic
we have the post request object and to
construct the post object we need the
subreddit and user details for that we
need the subreddit repository and odd
service classes let's inject these two
dependencies to our post service
now i'm going to retrieve the subreddit
from the subreddit repository by typing
subreddit repository dot find by name
and pass in the subreddit name
so if there is no subreddit with this
name we are going to simply throw the
subreddit not found exception
next we need the details of the user who
made this request we can get the user
details by calling get current user
method inside the odd service class
now we have all the needed objects to
get our post object
so
so let's inject the post mapper into a
class
and after that i am going to type
postmapper.map
and pass in the post request subreddit
and user objects as inputs to this
method
and lastly and lastly let's not forget
to add the written statement to the
method
okay now we are done with the save
method the important thing here is to
add the transactional annotation
let's add it on top of the class
and after that we have to implement the
method to read the port and after that
we have to implement the method to read
the post by different criteria
that means to get one post get so that
means to get a single post to get all
posts and to get the post by subreddit
and users
i'm not going to bore you by tapping all
the usual find buy methods so just to
make it quick i'm going to quickly copy
paste and the required code so we have
the method get posts here we are reading
the posts by querying the post
repository by id
using the find by id method
and if there are no post with that id we
are throwing the post not found
exception
and if we do find the post then we are
using the map to dto method from post
mapper we defined and returning the post
response back to the controller
similarly we have the get all posts
method and for the get posts by
subreddit we have to first read out the
subreddit details by id
and then query all the posts by the
subreddit
then we get a list of force back from
the
find all by subreddit method which is
defined inside the post repository
interface
and here we are going through each post
inside the list using streams and
mapping the post object to the response
post response object and finally we are
collecting to a list and returning it
back to the controller
the same thing is happening also here
for the get post by username method so
i'm not going to go into much details i
hope it is clear for you what's
happening inside this method before
testing before testing this let's go to
the post controller class and you can
see that for every method inside this
controller
i am wrapping the response we are
getting from the post service class with
the response entity object
so this is a class from spring mvc so
through this object we can return the
different status codes for different
scenarios
that means for instance if we want to
create a post usually if we are creating
a resource in rest world we should
return http status as 201 that means
created
we can do that by using the status
method and here i am passing the http
status dot created
enum value to this method
similarly for the get mappings we are
returning an okay status that means http
status 200
in this in this way we can have nicely
in this way we can nicely control what
kind of responses we are sending back to
the client
so okay so as we are through with this
it's time to start up the application
and test the functionality we have
developed so far
so i will be back once i have started
the application
so we are going to test our post api now
first of all i am going to login to our
app and get a valid json web token from
the application
once i receive this token i am going to
use it to create a post so here i am
going to throw in some dummy data
quickly
and call the slash api slash post api
with the http post method
so as you can see we received a 201
response back from the server that means
my request is successfully
so that means my request is successful
actually to be honest we have to return
the id of the post here so just the user
knows what what is the id of the post he
has just requested to create
but we can add that in the next sections
for now let's go ahead and test the get
functionality
so as i mentioned before we are going to
create the api to manage comments in our
application before starting the code
let's go ahead and see what all the
endpoints we are going to create in this
video so i opened the link for the
written tutorial here and if you go to
the section implement api for managing
comments you can see a table where we
have our required mappings along with
the http method and the name of the
method we are going to implement inside
our controller
so the first one is an endpoint to
create comments in our application that
would be a post mapping
and the path is slash api slash comments
the next one is the mapping to retrieve
comments for a particular post
here we have a get mapping and we are
passing the post id as a uri path
variable
and similarly we have our last mapping
to retrieve comments for a particular
user
which also takes the username as the uri
path variable
so now let's go ahead and start coding
inside the controller package i am going
to create a class called as comments
controller.java
and
and the first thing we are going to do
is to annotate this class with the usual
rest controller annotation
and after that the request mapping
annotation
and the value here would be api
api slash comments
lastly let's add also the lombok
annotation or logs constructor
now let's create our first method create
comments and annotate it with the post
mapping annotation
as this is handles uh as this is going
to handle the post request
this also contains a request body so
let's add the request body annotation
and now we have to create a dto class
called as comments dto which represents
the structure of the request body
so
inside this comments dto i'm going to
quickly copy the necessary fields and
paste them
and also the annotations we are going to
use
so we have the fields id
post id created date text and username
and here the text would be the actual
comment posted by the user
now let's go back to our comments
controller class and here we have our
request body now we have to convert this
object into our comment entity and save
it to the database as usual we are going
to handle these logic inside our service
class so let's create a comment service
class inside the service package and add
the needed annotations
i'm going to create a method called as
save which takes comments dto object as
input
now we have to map the data inside
comments dto to our comment entity
so if i open the comment entity class
you can see that we have the fields id
text
post created date and user
and we have the fields text inside our
dto as we saw before and the field
created date will be generated
dynamically and all we need is a post
and user to construct the comment object
now if you open the comments dto you can
see we have already the post id and
username fields so we just have to query
the post repository and user repository
interfaces to retrieve the corresponding
user and post objects
so
here i'm going to
show a small tip if you're using
intellij if you want to see multiple
editors at once we have this very good
option to split the screen vertically
and also horizontally so that if i want
to compare the fields i just can right
click on the editor name here and select
split vertically
now you can see more than two editors at
once this will come in handy when you
are dealing with uh the projects which
have lots of lots of files
and also another tip is if you want to
switch between windows you can use
control tab this is a key combination
this opens up a switcher window and
there you can see the file history you
have your file history and then you can
navigate through that by pressing tab
while holding the control key so this is
the shortcut i use every time to
navigate between the files
in the history okay now back to our
comment service class and let's inject
the post repository and user repository
into our comment service and inside the
save method i'm going to query the post
repository by using the find by id
method and by passing in the post id
so as this returns an optional if the
post is not available we can call the
orals throw block
and
inside that we will pass in a supplier
to throw a post not found exception next
thing is we have to determine the order
of the comment
so for that instead of using the
username we can check who is the
currently logged in user and use that
object to create our comment object for
that i need to also inject all service
class into our comment service
now we have all the necessary
information all we need is a mapper
which can map our comments dto to
comment objects
so let's quickly create an interface
called as comment mapper
which is inside the mapper package
okay so i've already prepared all the
method definitions and mappings inside
this comment mapper interface the first
mapping we have is for the
map method which takes in the comments
dto and the post and user and returns
the comment
so the first
so the first mapping is for the field id
so we are ignoring this uh id field
because
the id will be auto generated whenever
we save the object to the database so
there is no need to specifically mention
the mappings here that's why i've used
ignore equal to true value inside the
annotation
the next one is for the field text
here we are taking the text value from
the commons tto
object and mapping it to the text val
text field of comment object
and the next mapping is for the created
date field here we are evaluating an
expression a java expression
and i'm passing the java.time
expression to the java
to the expression field abstract will
evaluate the instant.now
expression and will take the written
statement and map it to the createdate
field
so you may ask me why did i mention
java.time.instant instead of just
writing instant because whenever map
struct creates the implementation class
for this interface
it will not add the import statement to
the class because we did not mention how
to so there is no explicit so there is
no way to add the import statement to
the implementation class so that's why
if we provide the fully qualified class
name then map then there is no need to
add import statements specifically so
these are the mappings we are providing
explicitly
next up is the method map to dto here
this is a straightforward
we have just a comment object coming in
as an input argument and we are
constructing and returning the comments
dto object here and the first mapping is
for post id
here also we are going to use the
expression
field and we are going to pass in the
java expression comment dot get post dot
get post id because we have the post id
inside the post object
and
similarly we are going to map the user
name to the common studio object by
using the expression
comment.getuser.getusername
now let's go back to our service class
and inject this mapper
inside the save method i am going to
type commentmapper
inside the save method i am going to
type
commentmapper.map and pass in the
comments dto
post and for the user object i am going
to make a method call to auth service
or services getcurrentuser method which
returns us the currently logged in user
so now let's store the written type of
this into a variable and to save the
object we need a comment repository so
let's inject that quickly and save the
object to the database
okay we are done with the save logic now
we have to also implement the
functionality
to send a notification email to the
author of the post so that means
whenever a user submits a comment on the
post we will send a notification email
to the
creator of the post
if you remember we have already built
the mail sending functionality
previously and so we can just reuse
those code and
so we can just use that code so i'm
going to go ahead and inject the
required components into a service and
paste in the required code and we will
have a look at it what's going what's it
and we will and we will use it and see
what it is doing
so you can see we are first building the
body of our email by using the mail
content builder once we get our email
message we can send the email by using
the mail service dot send mail method
and inside this method we are passing
the notification email object where we
pass the subject line of our email
followed by the email address of the
post author and followed by the email
message
so
once we execute this one we are already
sending the email message asynchronously
to the user
we have completed the implementation
part inside the service
now let's go to the controller and
inject comment service and call the save
method
now we have to send the response back to
the client that the comment is created
we can do that by returning a response
entity which takes the http status
object as the constructor argument as we
are creating a resource in the rest
world we'll send back the response as
status 201 or created
so we have an enum value called as
created inside http status enum so we
will return that value
so we will use that value inside the
constructor argument of response entity
let's create the implementations for our
two get mappings the first one is the
get all comments for post method which
takes in a path variable of type long
with name post id
inside this method we are calling
another method inside the comment
service with same name get all comments
for post
and we are returning the response back
to the client by adding the written type
of this method call to the response body
and finally we are sending the http
status as ok for this rest call
now let's create this method inside the
comment service and inside the method we
have to first query the post repository
to find the post by id
and as this method returns an optional
we can use the oral throw method truth
to throw a post not found exception
if we do find a post then we store it in
a variable
and we will find all the necessary
comments which are associated with this
post
by using the find by post method
as this method returns a list of
comments we use the stream and map
functions in the java 8 to map the
comment object to comment dto object by
using the map2dto method from the
comment mapper interface
finally we are collecting the result
back to a list and we'll return it back
to the controller
now let's create our last method get all
comments for user which also takes in
the path variable of type string and
with variable name as username
we are calling the get all comments for
user method inside comment service and
if you go inside that method
we are first querying the user from the
database and then querying all the
comments by the user using find by user
method inside the comment repository the
resulting list of comments we are
streaming and then mapping them to
comments dto objects and returning the
list of comments dtos object back to the
controller
we are also returning back the response
entity to the client similarly to our
previous method by adding the written
value from the service to the body and
the
and the http status as okay
all right we have completed the
implementation of the api to create and
read comments let's test our
implementation now by first starting up
the server and opening the postman
client
so let's open our controller class which
is named as vote controller and here we
have the annotations for our class the
rest controller rest mapping
and our logs constructor
and the risk mapping is for the value
slash api slash votes and inside this
class we have only one method which is a
post mapping so it's just its main
purpose is to submit a vote
um
for a particular post
and we are receiving a vote dto object
as a request body as input from the
client and if i drill down we have two
fields in this class one it is a vote
type
and the post id so vote type is an enum
which contains values for
either an upward or downward and we also
have a direction
field inside this enum so for the upward
we have the direction as one and for the
downward we have direction as minus one
and if you go back to the word dto the
other field is an identification of the
post so it would be just post id
back inside the controller i injected
the vote service class and inside the
vote method of the controller i called
the vote method of the vote service
class so let's go ahead into the word
service and this method is first
retrieving the post
which needs to be updated with the vote
so as this find by method returns an
optional we are using the orals throw
method here to throw a post not found
exception in case if we don't find any
post
and if you do find then we are storing
this written type inside the variable
so the next query is an interesting one
we are finding the recent vote which is
submitted by the user for this post
so as we are using spring data here
spring data jpa i created the method
find top by post and user
order by vote id descending so what does
it query do so here we are first finding
the user by post and the user
information
order those results by vote id in
descending order and get the top one so
what that would be so so we are just
getting the recent vote
by the user for a particular post so
that would be the latest vote by the
user so once we retrieve this
information we want to do some
validations here so we want to make sure
that the user is able to either approach
or download only once consecutively that
means if i uploaded a post
i should not be able to upload the post
again because i'm the same user and i
cannot do the same actions consecutively
the only value reaction at the time is
to downvote
so here we are doing this validation and
after that we are making sure that the
vote is uh present and if the vote
existing is the existing vote type is
equal to the requested vote type then we
throw an exception with the message
because we cannot throw the we cannot
vote in the same direction twice in the
row so now after this validation we do
either increment or subtract the vote
count of the post by one based on the
word type and finally we have to map
this vote dto to vote so and then we
save this inside the database
the same also apply for the post so here
in this method we are manually mapping
uh the all the fields so because i don't
like to create the mapper when we are
creating a small mapping logic just
mapping logic and
it's just one method so it's better off
putting this method inside the service
itself so and what we are doing inside
this method is to use the builder method
inside the wood dto
so we have this builder annotation which
will be
generating the builder method at compile
time
and so this builder method is used to
construct the object of what dto so
and as this builder methods name
suggests it builds the objects by making
the code more readable and easy to
understand so this is there's a design
pattern behind this method called as a
builder pattern
and you can read more about builder
patterns and
if you want to learn more design
patterns in general i highly recommend
you know going through the book head
first design patterns
this is a book which introduces you to
the design pattern and it's a very good
book okay let's move on and go back to
the controller so after saving the vote
information to database we just return a
success response back to the client with
status as ok
now we have to include the vote and
comments information when user is
retrieving the post so i have added some
additional fields inside the post
response class i added this comment just
for you to understand i will repo it now
so these new fields are number of votes
for a post the number of comments and
the last field is duration
so this field shows us the relative time
duration of the post creation time so we
are calculating this using a library
called as time ago so let me open the
github page of this library it's just a
cortland library
so we can also use it in our java
project here in the example
you can see that the time is displaying
as
four days ago a month ago and also you
know just now
so this is how you see the time stamp in
sites like reddit and also stack
overflow so let's go back to our project
i can quickly show you the dependency
information of this time i go library
inside the form xml file
and here we have this dependency
followed by the kotlin libraries the
kotlin standard libraries because
this is a kotlin based library and we
need to add also these dependencies to
our project the first one is the kotlin
standard library for jdk 8 and the
kotlin test
junit
dependency and for this dependency
kotlin standard library jdka to work
with our project we need to also add a
maven plugin
with
called as scotland maven plugin so this
is including in the compile phase so
whenever it finds some kotlin specific
code it
make sure to generate the java code for
it
and we are filling this value inside our
post mapper
and if we go to the post mapper if you
notice that i have changed
this from an interface to an abstract
class here
because uh
we have to add because we have added
four new fields into inside our dto and
we need some dependencies to fill these
details in the mapper that means for
comment count
we need access to the comment repository
and for vote count we need to access
the vote repository and also the odd
service is used to calculate the votes
uh word count so
let us see what we have what we have
changed here so after changing it to the
abstract class i automate these
dependencies as as i said before and our
first method
is a map which maps the post request to
the
post object
and here we have set the word count to
zero because whenever we are saving the
post the default vote count should be
should be zero
right there is no need to put any value
here so that's why i use the constant
field inside the mapping annotation to
send the value as 0.
if
i click on the green button you can see
the implementation here of this
particular
abstract class
so if you scroll down there is uh so
there is a line of code called post dot
word count as zero so the next method
here is the map to dto method here we
are mapping from post to post response
and the newly added fields here are the
comment count and the duration fields
so the first common count is actually we
are getting this written type from a
method so here we have this expression
field which is calling the comment count
method using for taking the post as the
input and this comment on method is just
returning the comments
um size of the comments which are which
belong to a particular post so it's just
returning an integer and the next one is
the duration so this is where we are
using the time i go library inside the
get duration method we are using the
using method of the
time i go library so this takes in a
long
variable as input and to get that long
variable
we are using this get createddate
function which returns an instant
and on this instant we are calling
a method called as to epoch milli
so this converts the instant to a long
long type and it basically calculates
number of milliseconds starting from
first january of 1970 until now so until
the created date so if you go inside the
documentation
now you can see it returns the number of
milliseconds since the epoch of
first january 1970. so the good thing
here is we updated our mappings and we
didn't even touch the post service class
because of this changes because we just
updated our post mapper class methods
inside this class and by creating this
mapper we are able to decouple the
mapping logic with with the actual
business logic which is handled inside
the service so that's always a good
thing to decouple our components right
so we have made all our changes we can
start our application and inside the
postman client
as usual make sure to log in and get the
authentication token back from the
server
and use that authentication token inside
the builder token section
and let's submit a vote to the server
now i created this body so i have
provided the watch type as
download and provided a post id
now let's test and send this request and
see what it happens and as you can see
the server responded with status that
means with status 200 that means okay
now let's see if the vote count is also
included in the post response so now i'm
going to
call the end point to get all posts
so here you can see that for the post id
which i used before the vote count is -1
as we have downloaded this post
so that means our implementation so that
means our implementation is working as
expected
and let's also test another case so if
we try to download the post again
that means one more time you can see we
have received the message you have
already downloaded this post
okay and the last thing i forgot to
mention is you can now see the duration
field inside the response
this is channel this is changing
dynamically now as i've you created this
post long time back you are seeing these
dates here like two months ago and six
days ago
as you are aware we are using json web
tokens for the authentication mechanism
and the main advantage of using these
tokens are they are stateless and easy
for the server to identify whether is
request coming from a valid user or not
so this may so this behavior makes
implementing a perfect logout solution
for the json web token based
authentication scheme in the backend
application very tricky and also
difficult
having said that there are four possible
ways we can implement the
json web token invalidation mechanism so
the first one is to obviously delete the
token from the client's browser so this
is for sure a must when we have to
implement the login but there is a
possibility that a hacker may have
already access to the json web token and
this and that is the reason we have to
find a solution to invalid the token
also on our back end
which brings us to our second point
which is to introduce an expiration time
for our tokens and make them as
short-lived as possible so ideally we
have to give an expiration time of 10 to
15 minutes for our json web tokens and
here i will be using the terms the json
web token and access token
interchangeably from now on so but the
downside here so as i was saying before
but the downside here is once the tokens
are expired we have to ask the user to
log in again which is
a terrible user experience so we can be
sure that this solution is bad
the third solution is to introduce a
concept called as refresh tokens which
builds on our point number two but the
idea is to provide the user an
additional token called as reference
token at the time of authentication so
we use this refresh token to generate a
new access token whenever the access
token is expired or about to be expired
so in this way we can keep on rotating
the access tokens and when the user logs
out we can just delete this refresh we
can just delete this reference token the
last solution is
when the user wants to log out we just
store the token inside a database and
once we have done that we check each
token each request and check whether
this request and check whether this
token is inside the database or not so
if this if it is part of if it is inside
the database then we throw an error
because this token is not is not valid
anymore
and
as i said before this solution defeats
the purpose of using a json web token
because we're using a state and we are
doing a database lookup for every
request
so
even though instead of using the
relational database if we use an
in-memory database like redis we can
hugely info improve we can hugely
improve the performance of this
particular solution so of ideally i
guess a combination of 0.3 and 4
would be the better solution in other
use cases but in our use case
we will just go with the third solution
and we'll see how to implement this
refresh token mechanism in our
application
the first step here is to introduce
expiration time for our access tokens to
do that i am going to open the jwt
provider class and inside this class i
am going to inject a value from the
properties file called
jwt.expiration.time
let me also add this
so i also added this property inside our
application.properties file with the
same name as a key and the value as 900
000
so now we have to change the generate
token method to include this expiration
token so i can do that by adding a new
method called set expiration
and this method takes in the date object
as input so for that as we have a long
we can use the instant.now dot plus
millis of the plus millis method call to
convert this long to an instant object
and from there we can use the date dot
from method to convert this instant to a
date object
and let's also add a getter method for
this expiration time as we will use this
method soon
let's open authentication response class
and here we will add two new fields the
first one is of type string and it's
called as refresh token and the second
one is an expiration date which is of
type instant now let's open
authentication service and inside the
login method we will enhance the
response we are sending back from the
method
so i'm going to add the expiration date
to the response by first getting the
expiration time in milliseconds from the
jwt provider class and from there i'm
going to calculate an instant from the
time step by using the instant.now plus
milliseconds method and for now we can
just pass in the refresh token as empty
string
and so if you try to perform login so
what we will get is one json web token
one and one refresh token which is empty
and an expiration date
now next step is to implement the
refresh tokens part first i am going to
add a post mapping inside the auth
controller class which takes a request
mapping value as refresh slash token
and this method is taking request body
of type refresh token request
this is a new class i have already
created and this class contains only one
field called reference token and this
field is annotated with not blank
annotation and if you add a valid
annotation before the request body
spring will automatically throw an error
if you pass in an empty or null value as
refresh token
i did not implement this validations
anywhere else in our application but in
a real world application we use this
validation mechanism very frequently
so now inside this method i am going to
add a method call to refresh token
inside the odd service class and let's
create this method
so before so before doing any more
implementation let's leave this aside
and create a class with name refresh
token service
this class will be responsible to create
delete and validate the refresh tokens
so the first thing i'm going to do is to
add in a method called as generate
refresh token
and here i'm going to create an object
for refresh token and this refresh token
is uh so we so we are going to store
this refresh token inside the database
if you go inside this class you can see
that we have the usual data entity and
all logs constructors the long block and
the jpa annotations and the first field
here is the id
and followed by the token and the
created date so we also have a
repository created for this refresh
token which is similar to all the
repository we have
so inside the refresh token service i am
going to create
a new object for the reference token and
set the token so for the token the value
would be uuid dot random uuid so this
will so this will create a 128 bit
unique random uuid and i am going to
convert this uuid to a string and we
will use this as our refresh token and
for the created date i am going to pass
in the present
time by using the instant.nav method and
after that i am going to save the token
by just using the save method of the
refresh token repository
and the next method is the validate
refresh token so this method is just
takes the token as a value this method
just takes token as input
and we are just going to look up for
this token using the find by token
method and as this method
returns as an optional
we are going to use the oral throw
method to throw a spring reddit
exception saying that this is an invalid
refresh token
the next one is a delete refresh token
method so this is just
the normal delete method so we are just
calling the delete by token method
inside the reference token repository by
passing in the bypassing in the token so
if the token is not there inside the
database spring automatically throws an
illegal argument exception in this case
now i'm going back to the refresh token
method inside the all service class and
here let's inject the refresh token
service
and down here inside the refresh token
method first i'm going to make a method
call to validate the incoming refresh
token
if the token is invalid then there will
be a runtime exception and if not the
execution goes on to the next step which
is to generate new token
we can use the generate token method
inside the jwt provider class
but if the jwt is already expired then
there will be no user information inside
the security context and as we need
subject while creating the token which
is the username
we can just
create another method called generate
token with username
and inside this method i'm going to pass
in the username which is coming from the
refresh token request as the subject
so let's call this generate token with
username method from our reference token
method
and let's store the written value as
string variable called token
now i'm going to construct
authentication response object using the
builder method we have our newly
generated token
the refresh token which is coming in
already from the request
the expiration date of this new token
and username
let's go back to auth controller class
we do not see any errors inside the
refresh token methods that's good and
now let's go ahead and create our last
method called log out which also has a
post mapping annotation
and here we are going to receive again
the reference token request as request
body from this object we can retrieve
the reference token and we can call the
delete refreshed and we can call the
delete refresh token method inside the
refresh token service
to make this work let's inject the
reference token service class inside the
auth controller
and lastly we can return a response
entity with status okay and body as the
refresh token deleted successfully
okay so a quick correction inside the
login method of our auth service class
so here in the authentication response
we are sending an empty string as the
refresh token so instead of that we will
be sending
the generated refresh token by calling
refresh token service dot generate
refresh token so this will return us the
string and we will pass this
to the authentication response
okay so that's it we have covered all
the points to implement refresh token
mechanism in our application
let's start the application and test it
so we'll be using angular 9 which is the
latest version as of today when
recording this video
and i am going to use visual studio code
as my ide for developing the front-end
application
so first thing first make sure you have
the latest angular cli installed on your
machine and after that open a terminal
and type ng new and here i'm going to
give the project name as angular reddit
clone
we'll be using angular routing in our
project so i'm going to type y
and for the style sheets we're going to
just use the css
and now angular cli is going to create
all the project files and install the
project for us
and i will be back after the
installation is completed
so as you can see the installation is
completed now and the project is
initialized successfully as a git
project okay now i'm going to type cd
space angular reddit clone and after
that i will type ng serve and our
application should start successfully at
localhost 4200.
so if you face any problems while
starting up the application one of the
root cause may be the incompatibility
between the versions of angular cli and
some dependencies of angular
this usually happens when you are
running an older version of angular cli
so to troubleshoot those problems i have
a section inside the written tutorial
based on the angular cli version you may
have to change the version number of the
angular dev kit dependency to be able to
start the application successfully
so if you open the address in the
browser you can see the default homepage
of the application
alright so the next step is to install
bootstrap in our project so in the
terminal inside the project folder npm
install save bootstrap
this should install the latest bootstrap
to our application
once the installation is completed you
can see that the bootstrap is added to
the list of dependencies inside the
package.json file
now we have to update the angular.json
file with the location of the bootstrap
css files
because the angular cli by default will
exclude the bootstrap css files when
creating the bundle
when starting the application so we can
instruct a cli to include these files by
going to the angularjson file and inside
the styles array we have to provide the
location of the bootstrap css file just
above the definition of styles.css
so i am going to type here node modules
bootstrap
dist
css
and there we have the
bootstrap.main.css file so i'm going to
provide this definition inside the
angularjson file
and save it
okay now it's time to create our first
component we will start off with the
header component we can create the
component by typing nggc which is short
form for ng generate component and the
name of the component we are going to
create is header so this will create all
the needed files inside the header
folder
okay so in this series i'm going to
mainly focus on the angular side and
i'll be explaining the concepts of
angular so i'll just copy paste the html
and css part and some bootstrap is
involved
so to start things off i will first copy
the needed html to the
header.component.html file so you can
see that we have a header tag and inside
that we have a nav bar
to the left side of the nav bar we have
the reddit icon this is an svg icon
which i copied directly from the reddit
website
and to the right side we have the login
and sign up buttons
so before checking how this html looks
inside the browser first we have to add
the app header selector to our
appcomponent.html file so i am going to
delete the existing code inside the app
component html and and i am going to
type app header inside the file
so now when you open the application you
should see this huge reddit icon to the
left side of the screen and to the right
side we have the links for login and
sign up now let's make this look nice
i'm going inside the
header.component.css file and i'm going
to paste again the required css here
so now if you open the browser you can
see that we have a very nice nav bar
where to the left side we have the
reddit icon followed by the edit icon
followed by the logo text and to the
right side we have the login and sign up
buttons
all right i know i told you our backend
implementation part is completed for a
dead clone application but before
starting to develop our angular
application i thought it would be good
to also show you the procedure to
document the rest apis we have developed
in that way we can refer to the
documentation whenever we need to write
the logic to make rest api calls to our
backend so now let's see why we need to
document our rest apis in the real world
you will be obviously developing a rest
api so that other clients can consume it
in our case the client is an angular
application it's always the best
practice to create documentation for our
api so that the other developers can
understand what they are working with so
in the real world having this
documentation is very helpful and
improves the user adoption of your api
and this also makes the maintenance of
the rest api very easy all right now to
implement this documentation in our
application we will be using an open api
specification called as swagger and a
library called as springfox which allows
us to automatically generate the
documentation for our rest api by
following the swagger specification so
as a first step open the bomb.xml file
and add the following maven dependencies
the first one is springfork's swagger2
and the next one is springforks swagger
ui
both these dependencies are on version
2.9.2 as the latest
at the time of recording the video after
that make sure that there are no errors
shown inside the pom.xml
and now i'm going to create a class
called as swagger configuration inside
our config folder
inside this class i am going to add the
configuration annotation and here i am
going to enable swagger in our
application by adding enable swagger to
annotation
and inside this class i am going to
create a bean
the name of the bean can be anything you
like so i'm going to create it as reddit
clone api
and here we are creating and returning
an object called as docket
and according to springfox documentation
a docket is a brief statement of the
contents of the document
you can configure this docket object to
decide what shows up inside our swagger
documentation
for now we will use the defaults except
for the api infos here we are calling a
method called as get api info which
returns an object of ipinfo inside this
method we are providing the details of
our api which are like the title version
number contact details and licensing
information if you want to have a simple
rest api documentation this is a very
good starting point and this
configuration should be sufficient now
we have added the configuration class
let's import this configuration inside
our application class i am going to
import this configuration using the add
import annotation in this way at the
application startup spring will invoke
springfox and springfox is going to scan
all the rest controller components in
our application and the corresponding
details for the stress controllers and
generate the rest api documentation for
all of these
let's start up the application and check
whether we are able to see the
documentation or not
once you open the browser go to address
http localhost 8080 swaggerui.html
and as you can see that we received at
403 error so this is because spring
security is not going to allow access to
this resource because we have configured
to block all the requests without the
token
we have already added some exceptions to
our security configuration so we can
also add the swagger ui.html
and some other parts to our exclusion
list
so this helps us to display the rest api
documentation webpage
once this is completed restart the
application and open the url inside the
browser
now you can see the complete western pa
documentation for our application
so you can see we have all our rest
controllers which are defined inside our
project here in the swagger
documentation we can see what are the
end points which are there in our
application including the http methods
they support we can also check the
models these are the request and
response classes which are also called
as dtos
and we can also see the example values
we can provide to the request payload
and which data type they support
and lastly you can also see the
documentation as a raw json by clicking
on the url localhost 8080 v2
api docs
so in the part 10th of the video
tutorial series we have already created
our angular application created the
header section
which contains the buttons for login and
sign up
so in this video we are going to
implement the signup functionality and
for that let's go ahead and implement
the signup functionality for that i'm
going to open the terminal
and type nggc or slash signup
this will create our signup component in
a typescript html and css file inside
the auth sign up
folder
now i'm going to open the written
tutorial and copying the
sign up component html file code from
there and paste it inside our project
after that let's also copy the css file
to the signupcomponent.css
now before checking out how this looks
inside the browser you have to add a
route from the sign up button on the
header section to the sign up page
if you check the signup anchor tag
inside the
hydracomponent.html file it's pointing
to the path signup
let's add this path to the approaching
module.ts file
where we declare all the routes which
are there in our angular application
and here i'm going to update the routes
array with the route information for
signup component
now let's go to the browser and check if
you are able to navigate to the signup
page after clicking on the sign up
button on the header section so perfect
it works now let's handle the form input
inside our signup page using reactive
forms
as a first step let's import the
reactive forms module inside our
appmodule.ts file i am going to add
reactive forms module just below the
approaching module and also make sure
that to add the import statement for
reactive forms module from angular forms
after that let's declare a variable
called as signup form which is of type
form group inside our
signupcomponent.ts5
and inside the ng on init i am going to
type this dot sign of form
equals new form group and inside the
form group i'm going to declare the
found controls for the fields we have
inside our signup form the first one is
the username field
so here i'm going to type new form
control and pass the form state as empty
for now
and the same thing also applies for the
other fields email and password
we can also add validations for this
field let's update our form control by
adding validators dot required for each
field and especially for the email field
inside the signup form we will also add
validators dot email to check the input
value for email field is in the valid
format or not
all right so we have made lots of
changes inside our signup
signupcomponent.ts file we have to sync
these changes also to our html file
so now let's open
signupcomponent.html and first let's
declare the form group directive for the
top form tag
and pass the variable signup form
next we have to assign the form control
names to the input fields
inside the input tag of the email field
i will type form control name in square
brackets
and provide the value email with single
quotes
if we do not provide single quotes
angular will check for a class level
variable with name email but we declared
this field as a form control so by so by
adding the single quote angular
understands it as a form control value
i am going to add the form control names
also for the username and password input
fields
and lastly let's add also the code where
we display the validation errors for
each field
so just below the input tag i'm going to
add a span tag
and inside the spanning tag i'm going to
add an ngif directive
and type signup form dot get
the single quote
dot valid
and sign up form dot get
email again with single quote dot
touched
and let's add text please provide valid
email
so what's happening here is
we have added the validators inside the
form controls for each field
so if the given form control is invalid
signupform.getemail.valid will return
either true or false
so if the given field is changed by the
user
and the value provided by the user is
not valid we will display this message
let's copy this and also adapt it for
the username and password fields
now let's check how this looks inside
our browser i am going to select the
input field inside the email and then
click somewhere else
so you can see that we receive the
message please provide valid email
address
the same thing should also apply for
username and password fields
perfect
okay now if there is an error let's show
the input with the red border for that i
am going to open styles.css file and
type
and type input dot ng invalid dot ng
touched
and then i'm going to provide the border
as one pixel solid with red color
okay now let's save okay let's save this
and go back to the browser and if i try
to change the input field and click
somewhere else on the page you can see
the error message along with the red
border on the input field
okay now it's time to take the input
from the form and make a http call to
our backend api
before that let's check the swagger
documentation we prepared
so i'm going to open the url http
localhost 8080
swaggerui.html
and under the out controller
expand the endpoint for signup
and here you can see the payload
which is accepting that is we need a
username email and password
so we already have those fields inside
our form
so let us create a model in our angular
application to encapsulate these fields
i am going to open i'm going to go
inside the signup folder and create a
file called as signuprequest.payload.ts
and inside this field i'm going to
create a signup request payload model
interface with fields username email and
password
okay now let's declare this model inside
of component i'm going to give the
variable name as signup request payload
and i'm going to initialize this model
inside the constructor
here i'm going to provide an empty
string value for each field
all right now we forgot to add the ng
submit directory to our form
which handles the on submit action
so let's quickly add it and
this ng submit directive should call a
method called as sign up
let's also create this method inside
your component
and inside the signup method i am going
to read the values from our form group
one after another and assign them to the
fields inside the signup request payload
i am going to access each field by using
the get method on the signup form
and accessing the value property which
returns the value of the form control
now we have our request payload object
ready next step is to make the http call
to our backend we will make that call in
a separate class called azure not
service
so let's create this service
i'm going to open the terminal again and
we'll type nggs
auth
shared
this is going to create an odd service
dot ts file inside the auth shared
folder
perfect
so let's open this all service class and
declare a method called as sign up
and inside this method we have to make
the http call
for that we need access to the http
client class inside angular
let's inject this class into our service
through the constructor
and after that let's come back to the
sign up method
and type this dot http
dot post and here i'm going to paste the
url for the sign up api
and we'll be receiving the signup
request payload as the input for this
method so let's pass this object as the
request payload
and lastly let's add a return statement
for this method and declare the written
type as observable of any
also as the response from the backend
call for the signup call is a string we
are going to change the written type as
text so now before accessing the http
client inside our service we have to
declare the http client module inside
the module.ts file so let's open the
file and declare the http client module
now let's inject this all service class
into the signup component.ts file and
inside the signup method i'm going to
type this dot
all service dot sign up and i'm going to
pass in the sign up request payload as
the input
as this method returns an observable
i am going to subscribe to this
return type and add some console log
and lock the response
so now let's open the browser and check
viewer now let's open the browser and
check if you are receiving a success
response
or not
so here what we are receiving is an
error response which says the request is
blocked by course policy
and our preflight request doesn't pass
the access control
this
we are receiving this error because our
back end is blocking the request because
we did not specify any course policies
yet so let's configure them by the way
if you are not sure what is cause i'm
not going to go into the details about
that i have already created a separate
video in my previous builder blog with
spring boot and angular series i will
add a link to the description you can
check that video and come back
so please check the video for more
information
so now let's go back and open our
intellij ide and here i'm going to
create a class called as web config
inside the config folder and i'm going
to add the configuration and enable
webmec annotations here on top of the
class
and i'm going to implement
webmvc configure interface for this
class
and i'm going to overwrite the add
course mappings
method
and this method contains all the
course related
configurations which we required for the
back end and here we are actually
accepting the request from all is from
all origins
to our backend if you are developing a
production grade application you may
want to not do this and read more about
what
are the right way to do
but for now this configuration should
resolve the problem we have with our
registration so let's restart the
backend application and try to register
one more time
so now you can see that we are receiving
the success response from our backend
so in the last video we implemented the
sign up functionality let's go ahead and
implement the login now the first thing
i want to do is
the first thing i will do is of course
create the login component
for that type nggc
login in the terminal
this will create all the required files
after that open the blog post which is
linked in the description
and copy and paste the html code for the
login page and paste it inside the
login.component.html file and next also
copy the css code to the
login.component.css file
now if you compare the css files of
login and signup components you can see
that the css classes login and sign up
share the same code
so let's extract this code from this
files and put it in a commonplace
styles.css file
the next step is to configure the routes
for our login page so so when you click
on the login button on the header will
be navigated to the login page
we can do that by first opening the
approaching.modules.ts file which is the
place we declare all the routes in our
angular application
and then i will be updating the routes
array with the path for login component
after that is done let's open the
logincomponent.ts file and let's
configure the form group with variable
name as loginform
and i'm going to initialize the form
inside the ngoninetblock
here we are defining the form controls
for two fields we have inside our form
which is username and password
and we also have defined the validations
that these fields require when
submitting the form now let's open our
login component html file and sync the
validations we did in the component.ts
file
just below the input text for username i
am going to add a span tag which is
going to access the form control
information through login form
form group and here if the user has
touched the input and did not provide
any value we will display the message
please provide a valid username
now i am going to do the same thing also
for the password field and in this case
we will display the message password
cannot be empty if you open the
application in the browser and try to
click on the input field and click away
on somewhere else on the page
you should see the validation message
and also the border is marked as red
all right so let's move ahead and write
the logic to make an http call to our
login rest api
similar to what we did for signup rest
api let's try to access our swagger api
documentation at http localhost 8080
swaggerui.html
and you see we've got a 404 error
this is because after enabling the web
mvc for the course configuration in the
la in the previous videos
we broke the swagger configuration
because now the spring mvc does not know
how to handle the web jars which is
coming as part of the swagger spring fox
library
and that below function just below the
course mapping method
so in this method we are pointing to the
location where the web charge and the
swagger ui.html can be found in the
class path
after that restart the application and
refresh the shraggerui.html page and we
should be able to see the swagger rest
api documentation again
expand the art controller and click on
the login api
section
and you can see this api accepts
username and password has the request
payload and it returns the odd token
reference token username and expiration
time as responses
so now let's go ahead and create the
models in our wrangler application to
hold this data back to the visual studio
code let's create a file called login
request.plo.ts
inside the auth login folder and let's
define an interface called request
payload
with field definitions for username and
password
both of them are of type string
and i'm going to also create a file
login response payload.ts under art
login
and also here i'm going to create an
interface with fields auth token refresh
token expire set and username now let's
open the odd service class under the
auth shared folder and add a method
called as login which takes the login
request object as input
and inside this method let's make a post
call to the login api
here we want to specify the written type
as login response by passing in the
generic type to the post method
and let's use the pipe method and map
method from the rxjs to map the response
to
and let's use the pipe and inside that
we will use the map method which is part
of rxjs
and we can access the fields which are
part of the response here now inside
this method we are going to store these
details inside browser's local storage
for that we need to add a dependency to
a project called as ngx web storage
let's add it to our package.json and run
npm install
once it is completed we can enable ngx
web storage in our application by adding
the ngx web storage module to the app
module.ts file just below the http
client module i am going to declare ngx
web storage
dot for road
and
and also make sure to add the import
statement from the ngups ngx web storage
package
all right now we are ready to access the
local storage from our application so
let's go back to our auth service class
and inject the class
local storage service from ngx web
storage
and once it is run let's store the token
and user information inside the local
storage by typing this dot
local storage dot store
followed by the key and value of the
data we're going to store
now the last thing remaining is updating
our login component so let's do that by
first declaring the login request
payload variable just below the form
group declaration
and i'm going to initialize this login
request payload object inside the
constructor
next i am going to create the login
method and read the username and
password values using the login form
form group variable and assign it to the
username and password fields inside the
login request payload object
and after that i'm going to call the
login method of the or service by
passing in the login request payload
object
and as this returns an observable let's
subscribe to this and add a console
statement called as login successful
now we are ready to test our
implementation so let's restart the
application to reflect the changes we
did to our app module the trees file
so now i'm going to open the application
inside the browser and try to log in
so you can see that we don't see that
nothing happens on the screen but if you
open the console you can see the message
login successful and let's open the
application tab under the local storage
and let's open the application tab in
the console and under the local storage
you can see the auth token and refresh
token information along with the
username and expiration time
as a first improvement let's add a
toaster notification to the application
so after every successful sign up and
login the toaster notification should
look something like how you see on the
screen
so first i'm going to open the
package.json file and add a dependency
called as ngx toaster we're going to use
the version 12.0.1 as of now because it
is compatible with angular 9
and after that we have to run the npm
install command to install this
dependence after that open the
appmodule.ts file and we have to add two
modules here the first one is browser
animation module which is coming in from
angular animations
and the next one is toaster module so
for that we have to type toaster module
dot for root which is coming in from the
ngx stores to dependency next we are
going to inject the toaster service
inside the sign up component along with
the router class
and inside the signup method on
receiving successful response you are
navigating to the login page and we are
also adding a query param called
registered with value as true
so we are using this to notify the login
component that registration is
successful in the case of receiving an
error response we want to display an
error notification so now let's go to
the login component and here we are
going to inject the router and toaster
service classes and additionally we will
also inject the activated route class to
the
login component to access the route
parameters which is coming in from the
signup component inside the ng on init
method we are subscribing to the query
params from the activatedroute object
and in case we receive a query parameter
with the value for registered as true
then we display the success notification
message sign up successful using the
toaster.success method and the next
thing is we are setting the value for
the field register success message we
will be accessing this message inside
the login component html file after the
successful registration inside the login
method we are subscribing to the
response we are receiving from the
allservice.login method and in the case
of successful login we are navigating to
the view to url
and then we are enabling the success
notification with the message login
successful
if we receive a failure response from
our login call
we are setting the value for the boolean
variable ease error and inside our html
file we have an ng if statement which
displays the error and asks the user to
retry
now let's go ahead to the main section
of this tutorial which is to handle the
reference tokens in our angular
application our backend server which we
have implemented expects the json web
token for each request and it checks for
this token inside the authorization http
header so we have to make sure that our
each request going from our angular
client to the backend server contains
this token this can be achieved by using
a special component in angular called as
interceptor
the concept of the interceptor is
similar to the servlet filters in java
in our case we need an interceptor which
modifies each request going to a backend
server by adding the token information
to the header and of course we also
maintain the logic for reference tokens
inside this interceptor
when the client sends an expired token
to the server
the server responds back with the 403
error
and at that point request a new token
using a refresh token
and using that new access token for
subsequent requests
now let's go ahead and implement this
logic in our angular application i am
going to create a file called as token
interceptor.ts under the app folder
and this file contains a class called as
token interceptor which implements http
interceptor interface inside the
interceptor method
we first read the token from our local
storage using the all service dot get
jwt token method which is just
retrieving the authentication token from
the local storage if the token is valid
we will be setting the value inside the
authorization headers if our json web
token is active this will this is how
the process works
now if the token we are setting to the
headers is an invalid token
we receive an error response from a
backend
in that case you have to prepare our
client to make the reference token call
to the backend and when we make this
call we have to temporarily block all
the outgoing back-end calls for this
user and once we receive a new
authentication token from our backend we
are going to release all the requests
again
so we are able to fulfill this
functionality with the use of a boolean
variable called as ease token refreshing
and a behavior subject called as refresh
token subject
which in our case acts as a semaphore to
block the outgoing calls
the main reason to use a behavior
subject instead of a subject or an
observable is because the behavior
subject can have a value assigned to it
so when we receive the new token from
the refresh token method we can assign
the token to the behavior subject and
access the new token
inside the interceptor coming to our
refresh token method if we check the
rest api documentation
this method takes in two fields as input
the refresh token and username
so we are constructing this object
inside the refresh token method and
making a http post call to our backend
for this post wall we are receiving the
login response object from our backend
as response and we are storing the new
authentication token and username values
inside the local storage
as we discussed before we are setting
the new access token value to the
behavior subject and setting the ease
token refreshing field value to false
or else all the outgoing calls will be
failing with the 403 error
okay now before we test this
implementation we need to create a home
page component in our application
for that i am going to type ngc home
this component retrieves and displays
all the posts we have in the database
so for that now open the written
tutorial and copy the html under the
create home page component section and
paste it into the home component html
file
i will be explaining what's inside this
file in the next tutorial but for now as
we are just testing the refresh token
functionality let's leave this as it is
so so i'm going to create a new service
using the command ngg has shared post
so this will create a class called as
post service under the shared folder and
inside the constructor i'm going to
inject the http client class to our post
service
and let's create a method called as get
all post
so now let's go ahead and check our rest
api documentation
so you can see this is just a normal
catch call and we receive an array of
object which contains all these fields
which are related to the post so now
let's go back to the vs code and create
a file called as post model dot ts
and inside this file i'm going to create
a class called as post model which
contains all the fields in the rest api
documentation all right now let's open
the home component class and here i'm
going to declare a variable called as
post
which is of type array of post model
and inside the constructor i'm going to
first inject the post service class and
i'm going to call the get all post
method of the post service and subscribe
to the response and assign the
response to the post variable inside the
component
finally we have to add route to the home
page component so open up the
approaching module.ts file
and add an entry to the routes array
just above the signup route information
and specify the component as home
component all right so there's a lot of
changes we have done we also need one
small change before we go ahead and test
the implementation
we forgot to add the css entry for the
ngx toaster library inside our
angular.json file
so let's quickly add it
just below the styles.css declaration so
let's restart the server just to make
sure that all the configuration is up to
date
and test our implementation
first i'm going to register as a new
user
and let's see if the sign up successful
notification is visible or not so we can
see this notification that's good now
let me quickly activate this user or
else we will not be able to login
and now let's try to log in
you can see we are able to see the
toaster notification with the message
login successful and we are also able to
see the post information which is coming
from our end this looks ugly but for now
let's leave it we will make it look
decent in the next tutorial but
in the last episode we just dumped in
the html code for our homepage into the
homecomponent.html file let's go through
it step by step and try to understand
the code so we just have a container div
and inside that we have another div with
class row
then we divided this row into two
columns one with the width of nine units
and the next column with a width of
three units
inside the first column we have again a
div which displays the post information
as seen in the comments and this div
element contains ng4 directive which is
looping through all the posts which we
are receiving from the post service so
if the post variable contains four posts
for example
this day will be repeating four times
and inside the div we again have two
columns the first column has one unit of
width
and as you can see in the comments this
section is used to mainly display the
vote information for our posts and
inside this deal we have two icons one
above and one below the vote count div
this element displays the vote count for
this post so these icons are coming from
the fort awesome library we will install
this library see how to start working
with this icons and so the next column
contains the post information
this div is 11 units wide and here as
you can see we already have all the post
information we need this column first
contains the subreddit name
and after that the name of the author of
the post and also the duration that
means how much time back this post was
submitted by the user the next field is
the post name
followed by the description
and the number of comments which are
associated with this we have another
icon in the section an icon for comments
we will also shortly see how this looks
now let's install the fourth awesome
icons in our project
the first dependency to add inside our
package.json file is angular font
awesome followed by font awesome svg
core and free solid svg icons
dependencies
these are the latest versions for each
of these dependencies at the time of
producing this episode
if you somehow provided an older version
number vs code automatically suggests to
update to the latest version so you just
have to click on the section and run npm
install
after running npm install we have to
enable the font awesome module in our
project so i'm going to open
appmodule.ts file
and add this module information under
the imports array and also make sure to
add the import statement for this module
from angularfont awesome library now we
have to import the required icons into
our home component.ts file from the free
solid svg icons library
so i am going to import the icons fa
arrow up
fa arrow down and fa comments
and these properties are already tied to
a html file through the icon property so
we just have to declare these properties
inside our homecomponent.ts file now if
you go ahead and open the application
inside the browser you can see the up
and down arrows along with the icon for
comments
but one thing which looks strange is
that the home component and the header
component are overlapping
we can fix that easily
we can fix that easily by adding the css
to our styles.css file
we basically added a margin top value
has 63 pixels for a body
if you go and check the application you
can see now the home component is not
overlapping with the header component
anymore okay now let's go ahead and try
to break down this home page to
different components
for that i'm going to use the screenshot
of the final version of the home page to
get an idea how we are going to refactor
this page
so in the homepage we have many posts to
the left side of the screen
and to the right side we have the
sidebar section where we can create post
and subreddits
and we have another section where we can
view the subreddits which are created in
our application so we are going to
divide this mainly into four components
the first one is called as post tile
component which contains the information
needed for each post
and inside this component we have a
voting section which contains an up
arrow a down arrow and the vote count
we will create a separate component also
for this section called as vote button
component the next two components are
the sidebar component and the subreddit
view sidebar component
so let's go ahead and create those
components one by one
i am going to put those components
inside the shared folder under the app
folder
because we can reuse these components to
display in multiple pages
now let's copy and delete the code which
is displayed just below the display post
comment
you can easily copy the code by first
collapsing the step element to just two
lines
and after that let's delete this code
open the post style component.html and
paste this code
as we are in a different component now
we no longer have access to the post
variable inside the post style component
as we are reading the post inside the
home component
we have to either move the code inside
the post style component or pass this
variable pose as input down to the post
style component i would prefer to move
the logic from the home component
because from now on this component
serves only as a placeholder so i am
going to go inside the
file and remove the injected post
service class and also the method call
to get all posts from the home
components constructor
and add it to the post style
component.ts file
let's also transfer the font awesome
icon properties to the post style
component.ts5
so the selector name of this component
is app post tile
let's go ahead and declare this inside
our homecomponent.html file
we should also add some css for this
component for that i am going to take
help from the written tutorial under the
post style component section
copy the css under the
poststyle.component.css file and paste
it inside the project
now inside the post style component we
have to extract the vote button
component so i am going to again
collapse the due section with class call
mg1
copy and delete it
open the
votebutton.component.html file and paste
that code
now to display the vote count inside the
vote button component we need also
access to the post information
so for that let's provide the post
object as input to the word component
so i am going to create an input
property called as post of type post
model
let's copy the selector for the wordput
component and declare it inside inside
the post style component.html file
enter the selector tag passing the value
for the property post let's also copy
the necessary css from the written
tutorial and copy it inside our
votebuttoncomponent.css file
next up it's time to add logic inside
the sidebar and subreddit sidebar
components
also here i am going to copy the html
and css code from the written tutorials
and paste it inside our project
now for subreddit sidebar we have to
read the subreddits from our backend and
display them under the section
let's quickly have a look at our swagger
rest api documentation and you can see
that we are receiving the following
properties as response for the subreddit
api call
for that first let's create the service
file which makes the http calls to our
backend i am going to create the service
using the command ng gs
which stands for ng generate service
subreddit
subreddit
this should create a
subredditservice.es5
under the newly created subreddit folder
now let's also create a model class
which holds the response from the
subreddit http call
i am going to create a file called as
subreddit response.ts
and i'm going to create a class which
contains the field id description
name and number of posts inside the
separated service first i'm going to
inject the http client inside the
constructor
and i'm going to create a method called
as get all subreddits inside this method
i am going to make a http call to the
get all subreddits api let's add the
array of subreddit response class as a
generic argument for the http get call
and specify the written type as
observable of array of subreddit
response
now let's open the subreddit sidebar
component file and inject this updated
service
and inside the constructor
let's add the call to the
subreddit.getall subreddits and let's
subscribe to this response and assign
the response to the subreddits variable
which is declared inside the component
this property is already bound to the
html as we have an nga4 directive which
is displaying the subject names for all
the subreddit responses now one thing we
have to observe here is the list of
subreddit response can contain any
number of records and if you just
reiterate and display all of them and
will face problems while rendering the
section that's why it would be a good
idea to limit the number of values we
display in this section
and if there are more than say four
records in the array we'll only we will
display a view all button which takes us
to a new page and display all the
subreddit information
for now let's add this view all button
to our section we can add that by
declaring a boolean flag first inside
the subreddit sidebar component
called as display view all and inside
the subscribe method of the get all
subreddits call if the response contains
more than four entries
we will use the splice method to take a
subset of only four values from this
array
and display those values inside the
section
or else we just assign the array as it
is to the subreddit property
before checking our refactored home page
inside the browser we have to make some
additions to the vote button
component.ts file
we have to move the fa arrow up and fa
arrow down properties
from the post tile component.ts to the
woodbutton component.ts file
and lastly i am going to copy the
selectors for sidebar component
subreddit sidebar component
and add them to the right column of the
homepage html file
now if you open the application inside
the browser you can see the list of
course along with the vote button
component the left side of the page
and on the right side we can see the
sidebar which contains the create post
and subreddit buttons
and below that we have the sidebar with
subreddit information along with the
view all hyperlink
let's start off by generating the
components required to create the
subreddits and posts
inside the terminal i'm going to type ng
gc
subreddit slash create subreddit which
stands for ng generate component
with the name create subreddit under the
subreddit folder
and after that i am going to type nggc
post create post
which generates the required files for
the create post component in the
previous episode we have already created
the buttons for create subreddit and
create post inside the sidebar as we
have now created the components we have
to add a route from the create subreddit
and create post buttons to this
components
inside the
approaching.module.ts file let's add two
entries with part create post and create
subreddits which point to the respective
component after that if you go to the
sidebar.component.html file you have
defined the value for the click
directory as go to create post
and go to create subreddit but we are
missing this method definitions inside
the sidebar component so let's go to the
component and here i am going to
implement these two methods
we have the logic to navigate to the
create post component inside the go to
create post method
and we also have the similar logic
inside the go to create subreddit method
where we are navigating to the create
subreddit route now let's go ahead and
implement the logic to create subreddits
from our angular application
i'm going to open the written tutorial
and click on the section create
subreddit and i'm going to copy the html
and css code and paste it into the files
inside the project
inside the create
subreddit.component.html file we have a
form which contains the form group with
value create subreddit form and an ng
submit directive which calls the create
subreddit method inside the component
inside this form we have a div which
contains the heading for this form
create subreddit next we have an input
of type text which holds the title of
the subreddit
we declare this field as a form control
by using the form control name directive
after that we have a text area which is
another form control which holds the
description of the subreddit next we
have two buttons create and discard and
we have an on click event which is bound
to the methods discard and creates
updated for these buttons using the
click directive now let's go ahead and
implement the required form groups form
controls and methods we need inside the
create
subreddit.component.ts file so inside
the component first we declared a form
group of variable creates updated form
which we saw before in the html file and
we are initializing this form group
inside the constructor with fields title
and description
each of these fields are assigned to a
form control object which contains a
validator which validates that the value
for the fields title and descriptions
are not empty
next we also declared an initialized
subreddit model object
if you remember we have created this
class in the last episode while
refactoring the form component then we
have the create subreddit method which
reads the form control values for fields
title and description
and then we are assigning it to the
subreddit model object
after constructing the object we are
calling the create subreddit method
inside the subreddit service where we
are making a post call to the create
subreddit rest api and returning an
observable inside the component we are
subscribing to this observable response
and when we receive a success response
we are navigating to the list subreddits
page
and if we receive an error we are
throwing an error using the throw error
method from rxjs
lastly we have the discard method which
takes us back to the home page so here
we are navigating to the list subreddits
page but this route and the components
do not exist yet
let's fire up the terminal and create
the components by typing ng gc
subreddit slash list subreddits to
create the components and html css files
now again i'm going to take the help
from the written tutorial
and here i'm going to go to the section
show all subreddits and copy the html
and typescript code
and paste them into the project so
inside the list
dot component.html file
we are using an ng for directive to loop
through all the subreddits which are
stored inside the variable subreddits
and for each subreddit we display the
name and we have an anchor tag which has
a router link with the value view
subreddit followed by the subreddit name
this route does not exist yet we will
create it soon and inside the other
column to the right side of the page we
have the sidebar component now if i go
to the list subreddits component we are
calling the get all subreddits method of
subreddit service
inside the ngoninet of the component
we are subscribing to the response and
assigning the response to the subreddit
object which is of type array of
subreddit model if we receive an error
response back from the get all
subreddits call
we throw an error using the throw error
method of rxjs all right now let's
register the route for slash list
subreddits to the list subreddits
component inside the
approaching.module.ts and after that if
you remember in our home page we have a
separated sidebar component which
contains a link to display all the
subreddits
let's go ahead and update that router
link value
now let's open the application and try
to create a subreddit
and as you can see we are navigated to
the list subreddits page and we can also
see the subreddits we have just created
let's also test whether the navigation
is working from the subreddit sidebar so
yes it's working perfect our next task
is to implement the functionality to
create posts we have already created the
components and the supporting source
files in the first section of this
episode before we start our
implementation we need to install some
dependencies to our application to
create the post we need some kind of
editor so for that let's use this editor
called as tinymce with all these fancy
controls and options
we can integrate tinymce into our
angular project by typing the below
command npm install save
tinymce angular
this should install and add the tinymc
angulardependency in the package.json
file next we will enable tinymce in our
project by adding the editor module to
the appmodule.ts5
alright so before starting the
implementation let's refer our swagger
rest api documentation one more time to
see what is the request payload we need
to create a post
so here under the post controller so
here under the post controller under the
create post section
you can see the payload which takes the
fields description post name subreddit
name and url
you can ignore the post id as this is
auto generated so let's create these
fields inside a class in the angular
project
i am going to create a new file under
the create post folder called as create
post
payload
and inside that i'm going to create a
class which contains the fields post
name subreddit name url and description
all right now we need the html and css
code for create post
i'm going to again go to the written
tutorial because i don't want to spend
time writing the html and css code
i think there is nothing special in that
so we will just emphasize in the angular
part so what we have here is in the html
file is a form tag which contains the
form group and ng submit directives
inside the form tag we have the create
post heading followed by the form
control inputs for post name and url
we also have a drop down list which
contains all the subreddits in our
application
we need this because each post should be
assigned to a subreddit
and the interesting part here is the
editor tag
this i copied from the tinymc page
if you go to the documentation here you
can see all the steps required to
install the editor in our application
which we have followed before
and lastly we have the buttons post and
discard so now let's see what's inside
the post component so we have declared
and initialized the create post form
variable of type form group inside the
ngoninit method
and inside the form group declaration we
define all the fields which our form
contains and we also added the
validators to this form control next we
are reading all the subreddit
information as we have to display them
in the drop down when creating the post
after reading them from the subreddit
service we are assigning the response to
a subreddits variable
next we have the create post method
which first reads the form control
values and creates the create post
payload object
once we have the necessary data we call
the create post method inside the
subreddit service which is making the
http post call to the create post rest
api
this method is returning an observable
so we subscribe to the response and once
we receive a success response we
navigate to the home page
or else we throw an error using the
throw error method from ngrx library
lastly we have a discard post method
which redirects us again to the home
page
now let's test our implementation i'm
going to open the home page and click on
the create post button on the sidebar
section and i'm going to provide the
necessary details here so you can see
the cool tiny editor we installed looks
something like this
so i'm going to use this controls and
provide some text
and click on the post button
and you can see we have navigated to the
home page if you scroll all the way down
you see the html code instead of seeing
the text in the expected format
this is because the tinymce produces
html code as the output and we are
saving this html code inside the dp
under the description field
first of all there is a security risk by
storing the raw html inside the db but
we will talk about it later
but for now we have to change the way we
are rendering this information inside
the post style component so let's open
up the post style component.html file
and under the div section where we
display the description i am going to
change the interpolation to a inner html
directive and pass the value
post.description to it
this will render our text as html and
now we are able to see the text as we
expect
so in the last episode we developed the
logic to create the pose in our
application but we still don't have a
way to drill down and read the post
information
let's create a component called as view
post
so i'm going to open the terminal and
type ngc
post slash view post
to generate the view post component
under the post folder so you want to
display this component when the user
clicks on read post button on the home
page
so first i am going to add a click event
for the read post button in the post
style.component.html file which calls
the go to post method by taking the post
id as input and inside the post style
component we first injected the router
class from at angular router package and
added the method go to post
where we have logic to navigate to the
url now to make this work we have to
define the route to view post component
inside the
approaching.module.ts file
so i have added an entry inside the
routes array where we are mapping the
path viewpost to the viewpost component
the next step is to write the html code
for the viewpost component i am going to
refer to the written tutorial here and
copy the html and css code from there
okay now let's see what we have in this
viewpost component html file
we are displaying the vote button
component using the app vote button
selector and passing the post object as
input to the component
we did not yet implement the voting
functionality in angular so we will
cover this in the next video which will
be the final video of the series so
moving ahead we have some sections where
we are displaying the fields subreddit
name username
name and description of the post
as we saw in the previous episodes our
description of the post contains html
code generated by the tinymc editor so
to render the html we are passing the
description to the inner html directive
now if we looked into the viewpost
component we injected the post service
and activated route classes into the
component and we are trading the post id
which is passed in as a query parameter
using the
activatedroute.snapshot.params property
i am going to access the query parameter
id
and the value is assigned to the post id
variable
in the next line we are calling the
method post from the post service which
takes the post id as input
and inside this method we are making a
http get call to our backend
this method returns an observable of
type post model
so we are subscribing to this observable
in our view component
and assigning the response to the post
variable
the next part is to add the
functionality for the users to submit
comments i am going to refer to the
written tutorial again to copy the html
and css code
okay the difference here is we added a
section to display
form to submit comments we named this
form group as a comment form and we have
an ng submit directory which is calling
the post comment method inside the
viewpost component we will have a look
at this shortly
and inside the form we have a text area
with the form control name as text and
submit button below the text area
besides this form we have a section
where we are looking through the
comments
and displaying each comment along with
the username of the commenter
now let's have a look at the view
component
and first of all we have declared and
initialized the form group called
comment form
we also declared and initialized an
object of type comment payload which
contains the fields text post id
username and duration
these are the fields which are expected
as part of the post comment api call
so inside the post comment method we are
first reading the value from the
form control with name text and
assigning the value to the text field
inside the comment payload object
after that we are calling the post
comment method inside the comment
service
i created this service under the comment
folder and injected the service to the
view component
if you go inside the comment service
we need the http client class to make
the back-end calls so i injected this
class into the service
and after that there are two methods
defined in this service
the first one is post comment method and
the second one is the get all comments
for post method which takes in the post
id as input and makes a get call to
retrieve all the comments for a given
post we are calling the get all comments
for post method after receiving a
success response back from post comment
method call
and once we receive a success response
we are resetting the value inside the
text area to allow a new comment
whenever we try to reload the viewpost
component we have to load the post
information and the comment information
from our backend
for that reason in the ngoninet method i
am calling these two methods get post by
id
and get comments for post
before we go ahead and test our
implementation let's have a look at a
bug which we have in our token
interceptor.ts file
if you are following along with this
tutorial from the beginning chances are
that it's not so hard to replicate this
bug
in fact we have not one but two bugs
let's have a look at them
the first one is inside the intercept
method where we are retrieving the token
from the local storage
and inside the add token method we are
cloning this request and adding the
authorization header
we are cloning this request because the
initial request object is immutable
but we are not passing the clone request
but the initial request as it is to the
next dot handle method
this is causing a 403 error because we
are passing an invalid jwt and expired
jwt
to the back end the second one is inside
the handle errors method
if we try to make multiple http calls at
the same time at that point of time the
auth token is expired we will try to
refresh the token multiple times
in this case we added an if condition we
allow the reference token request only
if there isn't any existing reference
token process going on
so in our case the first request wins
and request a refresh token but the
second request will fail silently to fix
this bug we will add an else condition
and we will use the filter on the
behavior subject until we receive a
non-null response then accept the first
entry in the behavior subject using the
take method and finally we will use the
switch map method to take the new token
and use it to make the request
now let's go ahead and start our angular
application using the ng serve command
by going to the address localhost 4200
so you can see there is only one post in
the database right now because there
were some test data issues because of
missing references of the foreign keys
so i have just cleaned up all the posts
in the database and tried to create
recreate them from the ui i also suggest
you to do the same
so i'm going to click on the read post
button and here you can see all the post
information
the comments which i've already created
before so let's try to create one more
comment
and you can see all the comments are
loaded successfully without the need to
refresh the viewpost component
now the next task is to display the
username in the header section
right now we are always displaying the
login and sign up buttons
so before we make any changes we have to
install one library called ng bootstrap
we will use the drop down menu in this
library so let's install this library
using the following command
i'm going to reference an image here
because i've already installed this
library but you can first we ran
first we are going to run the npm
install save ng bootstrap command and
after that i run the and after that we
are going to run ng add angular localize
command because there are some
compatibility issues for the
internationalization future between
angular 9 and ng bootstrap library after
running these commands we have to enable
ng bootstrap in our application by
adding the ngb module to the
appmodule.ts file
now we are ready to make the changes so
i'm going to open the written tutorial
and under the section displaying
username in the header section go to the
header component html and css files
copy the code and paste it into the
respective files
so we basically updated the header
component by adding a drop down from the
ng bootstrap library we are displaying
this drop down based on the value of
ease logged in flag if the flag is true
we are displaying the drop down and the
options in the drop down are profile and
log out
so we have some functions defined
through the click directive
we will be implementing the go to
profile we'll be implementing the go to
user profile function in this video and
we'll cover the logout in the next one
the user is not logged in we are just
displaying the login and signup buttons
as we have before
alright now let's open the header
component.ts file and here we are
assigning the value to ease logged in
flag
through the ease logged in method inside
the alt service
where we are retrieving the token from
the local storage and we will be
returning
and we are returning a true or false
value based on the availability of the
token
we have also defined the go to user
profile method where we have the logic
to navigate to the user profile page
we don't have this component yet so
let's create this component by typing
the command
ngc user profile
in the terminal
and once again i'm going to open the
return tutorial
and i'm going to go to the section
displaying user profile and
i'm going to copy the html code under
the user profile component.html file
and copy it inside the project so in
this page we should display all the
posts and comment information the user
has submitted
so we have some welcome text here along
with the number of posts and comments
submitted by the user
we are using this we are using this app
post style component here because we
want to display a list of posts
and lastly we are displaying all the
comments which are posted by the user
to use this post style component inside
the user component we have to make a
small refactoring
in the previous episodes we had the
logic to read post from backend inside
the post style component
now we have moved this logic away from
this component so instead of making a
backend call this this component
receives this pose it should display as
an input
so as part of this refactoring i also
changed the home component now we are
reading all the posts inside the
constructor and passing them as input to
the post tile component
we are doing the same thing also in our
user profile component if we open the
user profile component we are reading
the username
we are doing the same thing also in our
user profile component
we are reading the user name from the
query params using the activated route
class
and we are calling the get all posts by
user method to read all the posts by the
username
we are just making yet another http get
called to the backend and inside the
component we are subscribing to the
response and assigning the response to
the post variable
so we also calculate the number of posts
we received and
assign it to the post length variable
lastly we retrieve all the comments
created by this user by making a get
call to the backend
the same thing applies also here we are
subscribing to the observable and
assigning the values to the comments and
comment length variables
so let's open the application and test
the what you have implemented
so now you can see a nice drop down to
the right side and if we click on the
profile button nothing happens because
we did not update the routing module
let's quickly
because we did not update the routing
module for the user profile path
so let's quickly add the entry to the
routes array for the path user profile
now if you try again we can see the user
profile page and here you can see this
particular user have logged in has
posted one time and commented three
times
you can also see the post and comment
information in this page
so all right before we conclude this
video i'm going to point out two small
changes have done to the back end the
first one is inside the get post by user
method inside the post controller
i forgot to add the path variable
annotation
so we are going to add this path
variable annotation and we are going to
rename the
input variable from username to name
or else you will get an error when
trying to call this api
so the second one is inside the
postmapper class
for the post for the method map we have
added an additional mapping
for the field user
so without this mappings if you want to
try if we were creating a post it will
not save the user information
okay we have already created the vote
button component in the previous video
when refactoring our homepage
we have the upward and downward icons
and inside the html the click directive
for these icons is calling the upvote
post and download post methods but as of
now we are not doing anything inside the
components before starting the
implementation we need to create the
word service class where we can make
backend calls to the vote api
so inside the terminal i am going to
type ng gs
shared slash vote this will generate the
vote service class under the vote folder
which is inside the shared folder inside
the class we are going to first inject
the http client class and declare a
method vote which makes a post call to a
vote api if you open the swagger
documentation we need two fields as part
of the request payload vote type and
post number i have already created a
class called as word payload which
contains these two fields and field vote
type is an enum called as word type
where the possible values are upward and
downward back to the vote service the
vote method takes the
payload as an input and here as i said
before we are making a post call to the
backend now if we look inside the vote
button component we have first injected
the vote service
our service post service and toaster
service classes through the constructor
we declared and initialized the vote
payload object inside the constructor
then we have upward post and downward
post methods where we are setting the
word type for the vote payload object
and calling the votes method and this
vote method is setting the value for the
post id field which is coming as input
from the parent components and after
that we are calling the vote method of
the word service class which returns us
an observable and then we subscribe to
this returned observable and in the case
of a success response we are updating
the word details like the vote count and
also an indication whether this post is
either uploaded or downloaded by the
user the upward and downward fields are
newly added to the post model this helps
us to decide if a post is either
uploaded or downloaded by the user if
the user is not logged in then we
obviously don't see any indication
whether the post is supported or
downloaded so we are receiving these
fields from the backend so let's jump
into intellij idea and inside the post
response class you can see the two
fields upward and downward these two
fields are mapped inside the post mapper
class under the map to tto method i've
added two mappings for each field where
we are calling the methods is upwarded
and is downloaded which in turn calls
the check would type method which finds
the latest votes submitted by the
given user and compares it to the vote
type which is being passed in and we are
doing this only if the user is logged in
if not we just return false
so the next task is to implement logout
in our angular application
implementing the logout on the front end
is a simple task we just have to delete
the stored jwt and refresh tokens along
with the user information from the local
storage
after that we will make an api call to
the backend to delete the refresh token
so that it won't be possible to rotate
the json web tokens we can quickly have
a look at the swagger documentation so
here all we need is a refresh
request payload object which we can
construct it on the fly so first let's
go to the header component html5 where
we are calling the logout method inside
the click directive of the logo pattern
we are just calling the logout method
inside the earth service where we are
making a post call to our backend
this call returns a string as response
which we are just logging to the console
then we are clearing all the details
which are stored in the local storage
like the username authentication token
refresh token and expiration time
as we are in the service i would like to
show you a small change added to the to
the login method so here after storing
the token and the user details in the
local storage we are emitting two values
from this class the first one is the
boolean flag called logged in
and the second one is a string called as
username so these two output variables
are actually used in the header
component so you can see these two
fields are marked with output decorator
we are subscribing to these two fields
inside the header component and whenever
the user is logged in the earth service
emits these values to the header
component and we can see the user name
and the drop-down information in the
header section at the time
okay the next task is to protect the
secured routes in our angular
application that means some of the
routes in our application should only be
accessible when the user is logged in in
angular we have a concept called guards
which tells the router whether to allow
the navigation to a particular route or
not so there are different types of
guards but we will use the can activate
guard in our scenario to generate a
guard we can type the command ng g
g
auth auth which stands for ng generate
guard with the name auth
under the auth folder
you will be prompted to select the kind
of interface you would like to implement
as i told before we are implementing a
can activate card so you can select the
can activate option and press enter
now the guard should be created
successfully
inside the auth guard class i first
injected the out service and router
classes
and inside the can activate method we
are first checking if the user is locked
in or not by calling the is logged in
method from hot service
if the user is logged in then we return
a value true or else we redirect to the
login page
all right now the next step is to
configure the guards in the app routing
module so i am going to open the
approaching module.es file and inside
the routes array we are going to add the
can activate property for the user
profile create post and create subreddit
components and as this property takes an
array and we just have one single value
we just have pass in the
value auth guard
okay we have implemented a lot so let's
open our browser and start testing
first i would like to check whether the
logout is working or not so let's first
open the developer console and under the
application tab
local storage make sure that we have the
token and user details
now open the application
let's log out from the application and
check the developer console again
you can see that the values are not
there anymore so that's good but if you
check the home page you don't see any
posts or subreddits inside the sidebar
section
this is because the end points which are
supposed to expose this information are
secured
if the user is not logged in
then we don't provide the token as part
of the request and we don't get any
response back so we have to exclude
these two endpoints in our spring
security configuration i am going to
open intellij one more time and inside
the configure method of the security
config class let's add entries to permit
the calls to the get all subreddit and
get all post api
notice that i specifically mentioned to
permit only the get calls that that
means spring will not try to authorize
this calls for the token
in this way even the visitors can see
the post in our application
now i'm going back to the visual studio
code and here i'm going to show one last
change i did to the token interceptor
class inside the intercept method i
added an if condition where we first
check if we have a valid token and the
local storage or not
if yes then we add this token to the
authorization header or else we just
send the request without any headers on
it in this way we prevent unnecessary
errors in the back end because in the
previous way we used to always add the
authorization header even though the jwt
is null or undefined this fix brings us
a bit of consistency to our
authorization process so now let's go
back to the application and now you can
see we are able to see the post and
subreddits in the home page even though
i'm not logged in
now let's try to log in
and if i try to click on the upward icon
you can see the green color
and if you try to upload again you will
see the error message as a toaster
notification saying that we have already
uploaded this post so the only possible
action is download and if you try to
downward again
i again see an error message with a
different message now that you cannot
download the post
you can also upload and download from
the post page so let's click on the read
post button so we can see that the color
indication is also visible in this page
now let's try to upload and the arrow
turns green again so all right that
brings us to the end of the episode and
also the end of this tutorial series it
was very exciting to produce his videos
and i appreciate all the encouragement
from you guys
so thank you very much for that